d'alireza en premier donc on le voit
contre david howell
si on peut repasser voir rapidement sa
position
ça je crois que j'ai déjà vu donc c'est
pas rien de nouveau sous le soleil pour
le monde c'est italienne a toujours
aussi complexe
on va filer un petit peu comme en effet
hier on est beaucoup suivi la partie
d'alireza contre fabiano aujourd'hui
évidemment on a envie de voir maxime
contre le numéro deux mondial et ça fait
plaisir plaisir aide il est assis avec
avec une seule bouteille d'eau pour le
moment et un café
maxime est parti a remporté le concours
de marche seul
on savait qu'il était qu'il était pas
bien fabiano même sens la cam
seul face à ses démons le joueur
américain seul face à ses doutes seul
face à ces trous dans le cahier
il est pas bien
et ça marche
partie
magnifique
il regarde la veille six mois ça ça
c'est envoyé un peu derrière là c'est
qu'il montre toi
ça marche ça marche soit derrière
fabien nous concentrer
à c'est pas aussi facile qu'hier avec
les blancs pour le joueur américain il
ne peut plus réciter il va falloir jouer
les coups et quand il en a joué hier cd
pas toujours les meilleurs faut-il le
souligner
face à la machine française il va suer
fabiano
sassus en hausse a su côté fabiano je
préfère annoncer
faire rappeler les bases fait toujours
les mêmes gestes va-t-il se pose un peu
comme ça après on se met un peu comme ça
après on change de mains ce genre il ya
une routine comme ça comme ça comme ça
il fait il fait ça pendant des demi
heure en fait
une imitation llano
très belle imitation de fabiano quand
même très très réussie
j'ai pas bien fait je perds limitation
du gaz sur tik tok a dit grattage ça
repart
sur le nom de position toutes les vingt
trente secondes
terrible
mais là il est dans le calcul quand il
fait ça c'est qu'ils calculent fabiano
il sait pas où il va où vas-tu seul dans
le noir
mon ami sans lumière
c'est terrible
c'est terrible contre sens le frérot
voiçi sans lumière c'est sa salle dans
le noir
je pense que
je pense qu'il a plus peur que tu as
minières dans son live terrible pour
pour fabiano sassus beaucoup plus
c'est vraiment breton l'acier le
le ciel est en train de s'assombrir les
nuages sont en train de se former au
dessus du crâne de fabiano l'orage
pointe
à il avait un long soupir désespèrement
ouais ouais il n'est pas bien là a enfin
on reprend la petite position avec le
doigt
qu'est ce qu'il fait avec la main sous
la table attention maxime
serait pas mal d'avoir un petit peu un
petit peu de gel là pour fabiano pour
être bien sûr quand même
attention attention
ça réfléchit de nouveau
à sa calcul ça calcule c'est quand tu
peux vous dire que là ça doit calculer
bien est loin
à sa main derrière aussi ça marche ça
marche
ça calcule
il est vraiment en train de se poser la
question entre québécois trop il faut
aussi s'en fait ces deux coups c'est les
deux coups qu'il envisage
ça ferait étrange de voir où est le
candidat n'empêche surtout parce que tu
le verras pas frérot
ayari laver les mains moites 1 il
arrivait même pu ouvrir les bouteilles
il hésitait entre les deux coups les
deux coups doivent être bons mais
faut prendre une décision
en a il leur prépare à c'est sûr à 100%
sur hiller prépa fabi et 100% sur maxime
est en prépa
la 2 il ya deux choses qui sont certaine
c'est qu'il y en a un qui connaît
l'autre qui connaît pas celui qui ne
connaît pas
un drapeau avec des étoiles
terrible jaillira drapeau pas qui n'est
pas tricolore mais je crois que le
drapeau américain et les tricolores
aussi je pensais à trois couleurs
mais bon
bannière étoilée aide
ça se grattant la main
yahoo qui ne suit retraite sur sa chaîne
à parce que sinon on saurait qui
carreaux et pour maxime ce sera embêtant
par rapport à son public
on a tu vas voir qui va poser les mains
sur la table pour se lever il va glisser
se briser à mach en soit avoir pas non
plus espérer ça
avance que ce soit un titan mâchoire ça
pourrait aller mais
il faudrait peut-être des sopalin pour
pouvoir sexuées les mains fabiano
préfère pas famille je pense qu'ils
s'aiment pas trop les américains entre
bresse qui a réussi à y réussit encore à
ouvrir la bouteille
sabots un petit peu d'eau
c'est pour mieux retenir le sel
est en train de se former côté côté
fabiano
petites urgences et jamais c'est jamais
bon sinon une petite gorgée comme ça ces
signes d'inquiétude un
ça ça veut dire que tu sais plus où tu
en es que tu as peur
et j'ai envie de te dire ça ça change
dans la bouche et
et sa dessèche à d'autres endroits côté
fabiano
alalala il est pas bien là la très très
clairement il a un moment difficile à
passer fabiano mais va fort que maxime
se se sublime dans cette partie il a pu
avoir par le passé un petit peu ce
défaut quand il prenait des petits
avantages contre le top top niveau de
les laisser un peu filer tels des
anguilles entre les doigts comme ça à
qui glisse un peu la rage passé déjà
touché des poissons dans la mer la cda
trappe et il te glisse entre les mains
avec leurs écailles il va falloir que
maxime que maxime ne laisse pas glisser
qui réussissent à l'attraper à lui
mettre des petites carottes comme ça
pour pas qu'ils s'échappent
c'est vrai que ça un défaut de maxime
dans le passé dans son jeu de terminer
comme ça les joueurs du top top top
et aujourd'hui il faudra pas laisser un
chouïa un iota des espaces aux joueurs
américains parce que lui de glee serait
entre les doigts il repartirait nagé en
haute mer
il va falloir prendre l'épuisette
peut-être et le mettre dans les filets à
fond de faire une petite plante chaplin
qui parle
du coin kiev
chante prochain coup de famille ça
égalise voir ça gagne
mais la boule au ventre ah ben boulot
voit en train normal voilà peut pas y
avoir plus de pression qu'aujourd'hui
hier
à la pression là elle peut pas elle peut
si vous n'avez pas la pression pour la
partie d'aujourd'hui faut plus jamais
regardé deux parties d'échecs un les
frérots je vous dis tout de suite si
vous si vous ne ressentez aucune
pression et aucun enjeu quand vous
regardez cette partie enfin juste
arrêter de regarder deux parties
d'échecs en fait à vitam aeternam en
fait ça sert plus rien en vrai c'est ce
genre de parties qu'on a envie de gagner
ce genre de parties qu'on a envie de
voir
c'est une erreur qu'on a envie de voir
côté fabiano ici
déjà plus de 20 minutes de réflexion
pour le joueur américain
dubitatif face à la prépa présidentielle
il est du père
après une façon faut aussi cecab quatre
ont tous les deux d'être tous les deux
l'air d'être des coûts convenable pour
le moment c'est après que le piège
risque de se refermer sur fabiano
ou pas
ou pas voilà j'ai envie de te dire je
lâche pas d'un fonds n'en sait rien
sinon il ya une heure juste magnifique
échec alors ça pourrait être le cas
c'est un échiquier alpha échec
oui si c'était un échiquier alpha échec
en oliviers
avec un petit autographe du président là
je dirais oui pourrait imaginer qu'ils
soient simplement en train d'admirer
le chef-d'oeuvre d'art contemporain du
de l'artiste salvatore bacrot très très
connu 1 salvatore braqueront grand
artiste mais là c'est simplement des
échiquiers dgt donc il n'y a rien
d'exceptionnel c'est chic est donc dont
il est vraiment
en difficulté devant la position
mc il écrit très mal
entre-temps les rêves est demandé de
bien décrire
léonard qui regarde au débat qui
va la d le troisième charbon à la chicha
ça c'est sûr que ça envoie la chicha
derrière
fait cette donne quoi au fou 17 ça
paraît trop pleutres non mais ça il va
faire flouer 6 pour contrôler des cinq
soit faire cavalier b4 mais là il va
jouer pour la case dessins qu'elle est
trop important de cette case
20 km et quatre mairies des quatre qui a
aidé 4 qui a été quatre pourquoi pas
après
pierre hellier prend on prend qui a valu
aux deux essais 5
je sais pas peut-être car il y avait
quatre ont bien contrôlé les cases et on
tape sur blanc
près peut-être pas le temps de fou
bessette des cinq mais j'y crois pas
trop à ça
il fout des sept balles travaillées va
bien on dessine qu un
beauf qui ont bouffé là tu as des
problèmes avec le cheval et bk tête des
cats maintenant je sais pas
ça semble contresens à vrai dire
il faut aussi ce nom mais c'était sûr
c'était où vous aussi soucaret les b 4 à
vrai dire
j'étais sûr c'était soit l'un soit
l'autre là c'était c'était un choix deux
options
après
cavaliers dessine qu ici va sûrement
être le coup de maxime
et dans l'autre partie avec fou prend
des 5 alors là est ce qui peut reprendre
du pillon et garder le fouet du coup
faire la nouveauté ici car elle et
bekaert des quatre est ce que ça ça peut
être une idée
ça peut être intéressant à mon avis sur
des pions prend cavaliers prend
cavaliers prend des cinq cavaliers
appsync aux cavaliers ces six semaines
ça tape donc arrivé à lille à mon avis
l'idée ça être ça car il y ait des 5 fu
prend pas fou prend comme blé dur à mes
pions prend cavaliers b4 des quatre pour
garder le fou qui tape le 4 cavaliers g5
très complexe
ça c'est très complexe
ça peut être une idée j'en sais rien
ici on n'a pas très envie parce qu'après
francs les noirs colmate le centre
avoir un
une menace directe c'est fou prend b3 à
vrai dire ce qu'ils attaquaient deux
fois
l'hôtel à lyon à trembler ah ben
j'espère un fab dans la partie la halle
et
elle est très tendue toi en tant que
spécialiste espagnol tu dois te régaler
mon fab
et car il est des six co qui par tempo
ça c'était sûr on est dans la prépa de
maxime faut aussi c'était coup mène donc
forcément
s'était vue qui a aidé ça que l'on va
repartir en marche un petit peu
peut-être
nom reste
c'était sûr que ça allait tempo là on
est dans la prépa
ne pas laisser languit se faufiler à
vernon laon guillaume et des petites
carottes sur le bout de la tête un
terrible
pour le moment ça se passe ça se passe
très très bien la phase d'ouverture
ça se passe vraiment bien maxime il est
à l'aise dans sa partie il a réussi à
planter une surprise à fabiano
clairement il est bien
la pression pour kara no 2 centièmes on
a préparé un cahier dans la tranche
qu'on n'arrive pas à s'en sortir et ça
repart et ça repart
fabiano qui reste avec ses doutes pour
le moment mais attention hein attention
maxime il va falloir rester dans la
partie
y a pas enlevé trois tours prend b3
ferait plaisir dame prend b3 merci au
revoir un
ça ce sera un coup de frais reprise b3
abala ça met tout de suite très bien
ces cas la charge gratuite
maxime a passé beaucoup plus de temps
debout cassis à oui mais bon il faut
aussi dire que la compétition de marche
qui a lieu en ce moment à riga est bien
plus importante pour maxime que le
tournoi d'échecs 1 il vient tout d'abord
remporté la compétition marche
et après et après si la compétition de
marche se passe bien il ya le tournoi
d'échecs accessoirement
hélas non
j'en profite pour jouer le tournoi mais
non
vous prend des cinq way
et là je pense la nouveauté sa
rédemption prends je m'attends à une
surprise
là c'est sûr qui connaît n'en fout prend
hockey suit la partie
je suis inquiet pour fabiano en vrai
parce que ça a l'air de bien connaître
côté maxime
ok
prenez 5 ou va être le problème pour
fabiano est la difficulté
les
b4y v3c 5
m'a pas l'air dangereux mais si ça doit
être dangereux
doit être dangereux
dangereux un truc comme ça
ça une tête de dangereux en tout cas va
avoir un vraiment fabiano a l'air de
réagir parfaitement
positionné dynamique et assez
mondial ça assez déséquilibré en fait
parce que les structures sont bizarres
pour les deux joueurs ça joue que au
tempo prêt à l'activité il n'y a pas
vraiment d'enjeu stratégique c'est vrai
que ce fou est mauvais mais d'un autre
côté la structure est mauvaise de ce
côté là le fou on peut peut-être le
réactiver un jour par f5 quatre fois f6
à vrai dire c'était plus des problèmes
concrets ici pour les noirs la colonne a
éventuellement le pion c7 la difficulté
à se développer
et j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque fois ça
à peu près seul coup
si on met deux peut se retrouver en
l'air est menacée je vois je veux juste
dire par là que y'a pas vrai il n'ya pas
d'enjeux stratégiques ici à des enjeux
stratégiques mais en réalité c'est une
position de calcul c'est une position
ouverte et ça joue autant prêts quoi
soit
c'est les noirs soit a pas le temps en
fait
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment ça la
question
phocéen peut aller voir ce qui se passe
à côté un rapidement
senti vraiment tout fait à quoi que ce
soit
[Musique]
irujo well
on ne se passe rien de spécial vite
yougov op art in
blizzard sa
pension à vie tube enfin
attention à vite yougov
je sais qu'il ya dix ans 17dans 7,20 à
dans ses variantes là
attention il vient de gagner chauffée à
des états unis pourrait être dangereux
shirov il est où
oué shirov
shirov
n'arrive pas à voir chez rough
ryu jong il
avait blanchi pas si ma tante aline ou
pas
je veux dire aux fans hikari krishna
ça joue un peu de partout pour le moment
on n'en sait pas vraiment plus
il peut aussi fabiano jouer cavalier b4
à vrai dire
attaqué le fou c4 c6
est joué pour des 5
il a l'air de se poser des questions
fabiano
une maxime c'est les prend on prend kébé
cap des 4
14 points 4 et prend des cinq là mais ça
a l'air d'être coupe pour les noirs non
langage corporel 2 maxime est assez
rassurant je suis d'accord
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
mais bon pour le moment on n'a pas
dessus sur l'échiquier
pour le moment on n'a pas dessus sur
l'échiquier encore
alors s'il arrive à faire quelque chose
note maxime
bon
en tout cas on peut être confiant sur
sur la prépa qui doit être profonde
après comme je vous dis là on peut pas
on peut pas réussir à analyser la prépa
au même niveau que c'est impossible
ça me sens joueur bref surtout que 4300
woerth chaise comme en mille ou 1100 en
réalité photos furent enlevées de 3000 1
c'est terrible
max qui repart
ça se passe bien
pour le moment
parfait
c'est parfait
jouer j'ai raté pendant que chercher des
infos sur le fun
je comprends bien évidemment tempo et la
fabiano devrait jouer rapidement le
prochain coup
logiquement équivalent et b4 écoutez
c'est la position qu'on a eu en tout
premier un conte à quel on a pensé une
demi-heure sans vraiment savoir
finalement
si c'est bon ou pas
mais maxime c'est sûr qui connaît encore
un c'est sûre à 200% même
koné obligatoirement il a toujours été
menées jusque là c'est la variante qui
par email et dames b3 c5 il connaît
forcément
là il envoie le dame b 3 ça suit cette
partie 1-2 et c5 on a sept grandes
positions
on s'était pas trompé ici on ne s'était
pas trompé quand on avait parlé
de cette variante on avait huit cette
position aussi sans vraiment réussir à
la juger
et alors là question
c'est ce que les blancs sont mieux ou
pas ouais c'est maxime qui va réfléchir
ici
maxime qui va prendre son temps ça et
fabiano il sent qu'il est il a réussi à
sortir
de la première embuscade
pakistanaise et y retourne il retourne
se promener un petit peu
on her prépa probablement après il est
possible que fabiano est connu et qu'il
ait réussi à se rappeler il est possible
que maxime connaissent plus on peut pas
exactement savoir mais il semble que
fabiano et suez et qu'il a réussi soit à
se rappeler
soit à trouver
et maintenant maxime à la position
qu'ils souhaitaient avoir
alors est ce que la question déjà c'est
ce qu'on prend passants ou pas parce que
comme le pion vient d'avancer en c5 si
on veut le prendre c'est maintenant ou
jamais
c'est une question en fait c'est juste
une question j'en sais rien maintenant
propose tour à quatre tours à 4 l'idée
c'est de s'en prendre aux cavaliers de
le manger au prochain sur quoi les
découvertes comme cavalier des simples
cavaliers detroit ces prises instante
donc probablement qu'à rallier ses six
damas trois cavaliers t4
vallier prendre ses empreintes
elle a peut-être on peut jouer le pion
bay a plutôt joué je prends j'imagine
toujours à 7 ça assez forcé
refus l'idée ça suffit ou pas en fait ça
reste très concret comme position le
problème c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à voir
un truc stratégique c'est concret
c'est une possibilité de jouer comme ça
c'est une possibilité
prendre en passant avaient rien donné
dans l'autre partie
l'idée c'est que s'ils prennent de ces
les noirs on a le pion dépassé quand
même
et le fou a du mal à se redéployer
ouais donc par déduction si on comprend
que la partie avec dc a fait nul que vos
turdine de retour à quatre avec ce qu'on
a fouillé torah cas doit être le coup et
maxime connaît encore maxime connaît
c'est sûr il va envoyer tour à 4 il
connaît encore
c'est évident
il connaît encore ici
pas assez de temps de
de concentration est
passé de calcul des petits des petits
coups vers le regard vers l'eau il
connaît à icônes et icaunais il connaît
ouais
il connaît maxime
l'aï connaît encore c'est sûr je connais
le loustic c'est pas de l'impro là
et je pense qu'ils se rappellent assez
loin
qui se rappelle encore assez loin à vrai
dire
qu'ils essayent de reconstruire le truc
mais je pense qu'il sera pas là c'est
loin
là ils repassent le fichier dans sa tête
après s'il va bien tous les coups on
peut rien y faire malheureusement les
échecs
assistâmes à
4/4 et à six dames c'est katia et ses
sets c'est une autre option
son coût latrines 5 avaya ci serait
parce que qu'est siskid à 23 qui est des
cats avaient l'air vraiment dur à jouer
pour les noirs peut-être ça allait
peut-être ses cavaliers à six lames c4
qui essaient 7
ça a l'air très dangereux pour les noirs
en fait
tous les autres cas ici dans mon
avantage blanc
c'est très dur alors
alors sept y'aura
et ces six stations plus logique à celle
que j'avais envoyé un tweet ivement
aircelle serait bizarre oui et non parce
qu'il attaque des cinq ans quand même
mais toi tu as peur de te prendre 1 fois
5 c'est surtout ça
bientôt ça va être très dur à défendre
pour famille
il peut y arriver mais ça va être
vraiment difficile maxime lemieux au
supplice à
la vidéo elle sait mieux sortie de
l'ouverture que maxi que fabiano caruana
a dit là il donne l'impression d'en être
sorti
tension alireza ça peut être dur un
psychologiquement ce qui s'est passé
hier
et attention aux copains qui peuvent
remonter notamment vite yougov
pour avoir un aller au bal ou candidats
non alireza y perdra pas et ça va
remonter derrière
mais c'est ali reza craque après howell
away
le scénario idéal pour ol c'est que
maxime gagné que lui gagné à la dernière
ils font nul
et il espèrera que sondés partagent
suffisent parce que s'il a autant de
points que maxime en fait maxime veut
toujours nul contre lui
parce que c'est la meilleure des
partages maxime
je pense qu'on va lui faut deux sur deux
malheureusement pour le candidat
normalement il va jamais gagné
aujourd'hui déjà et même s'ils gagnent
aujourd'hui en fait il a tellement un
départage pourri qu'il faudra encore
tenir maxime quoi
le maximum les blancs oui
c'est bon pour moi voilée besoin de
victoire à mes oreilles je pense qu'il
s'en fou d'aller aux candidats on n'est
pas content en fait
peut-être même possible qui préfère ne
pas y aller
arrive la va faire une telle par action
pour éviter de faire un ennemi sur 14 ou
2 sur 14
string et du travail je passais de 1600
à 2000 200 lots en deux ans où la jolie
progression
la grecque s'en fout diallo candidat à
mais
imagine pas en fait
c'est un calvaire qu en compte a pas le
niveau 1 de jouer 14 rondes contre des
joueurs
du top level
c'est un vrai calvaire
jurisprudence wang hao
c'est terrible c'est vraiment difficile
psychologiquement c'est très difficile
de joindre en vain comme ça quand tu
n'étais pas assez fort
imbécile c'est quoi le souci d'un bébé
si c'est une mauvaise tête mais je peux
pas dire pourquoi
là je peux juste prendre prendre et
ramener une tour en quatre
étapes et le pion en fait
maintenant tour à 4 la fabiano
il va passer un très mauvais moment
aujourd'hui maxime en train de lui
rendre la monnaie de sa pièce en est et
en plus il lui rend la monnaie en en
francs pakistanais en cas kibaki cette
année mais ça ça fait très très mal
c'est vraiment pas un le type de monext
envie de ramener chez toi tu as des
bustes de baky qui sont comme on appelle
ça
estampillée estampillé sur sur la pièce
c'est terrible c'est terrible
frappe et voilà c'est frappé pas
estampillé frappé ses frappes et des bus
de baky serraf
terrible
on va qui cette année pèse 12 kg vois ça
c'est des contrefaçons l'utilisent bas
qui bat qui a fait des pièces de 35 kg
alors évidemment pour un bas qui cette
année c'est assez léger 1 ça tient dans
les poches mais c'est vrai que pour des
personnes normales ça peut être un peu
un peu lourd mais si on en a refourgué
de 12 kg c'est de la contrefaçon
catanèse un
temps sur moi
caf habits fabick issue
/
même quand c'était choquant estime qu'il
ya des prépas se fait plus voir l'
inverse est-ce que vous avez réfléchi de
pourquoi c'était comme ça pour ceux qui
ont commencé à regarder les échecs il ya
à peu près un an pourquoi est-ce que
c'est toujours maxime qui prend les
prépas contre fabiano ou personnes s'est
jamais posé la question parce que c'est
trop dur
à chaque fois ci il y avait les blancs
et
ouais
c'est incroyable en fait c'est pour ça
qu'il ya beaucoup de
[Musique]
déchet kicks qui parle qui parle qui
parle qui parle mais mais qui
réfléchissent pas en fait qu'ils savent
pas c'est pour ça que
c'est difficile de parler quand on n'a
pas un certain bagage quoi jean michel
joue aux échecs depuis deux ans et parle
est ce pas qu'une question de temps j'en
ris moule qui est déjà main au dessus de
2000 je pense pas qu'il se fasse ce
genre de réflexion c'est en deux temps
de jeu plus
puis ce niveau de jeu quoi
faut brancher son du charisme exprime
prépa avec les blancs est grande chez
sur bucarest raconter pourquoi c'est un
tour à church a encore qui comptait pour
rien
c'est n'importe quoi ce grand chester
bucarest s'est placée juste après les
candidats en roue libre total c'est pas
des toits qui compte ça candidats mac
s'est pris une grosse préparer avait les
noirs et là il prend gros se préparent
ils à lait noir estime que phil capoue
il jouer à wii jouer gros il avait les
noirs
la grosse partie maximale et blanc ils
plantent une prépa normales en fait
c'est tout fait normal
ça suit ça suit la logique
ça suit la logique
c'est tout à fait normal
c'est vrai que les blancs contre karine
à la coupe du monde
ça arrive que maxime soient préparés
aussi avec les noirs par exemple sa
dernière partie aux grandes chaînes ce
tour il avait il été très facilement
sorti de la prépa de caruana avec les
noirs ou six
noms mais je pense qu'à partir d'un
certain niveau faut arrêter de parler de
prépa en fait je pense qu'il faut faut
pas que vous entendiez de life là dessus
ouais
en fait c'est compliqué mais
c'est dur de comprendre
d'ailleurs en conclusion de compte car
yakine maxime il n'a vraiment pas de bol
entre kariya keynes était la berlinoise
marci dans tout le temps dedans fabiano
avait toujours carla qui n'avait tout
jouer mais il a fait nul voilà enfin ça
arrive
quand même que qui est très bien
préparée qui connaît bien la théorie
laquelle points loin en connaissance
d'un maxime où là c'est pas loin c'est
eux
c'est stratosphérique mon loin devant
maxime icaunais quasi rien en fait
si maxime c'est quand on est tous deux
déjoué contre maxime se serait
pas un péno quoi
mathieu devait jouer contre maxime
il a pas en rougir en fait c'est juste
que
tout ce qui est en dessous de 27 20 à 27
30 au noir cp non on avait vu navarra en
cp nous tout le temps qu en fait
même dans l'ouverture à bah oui allez
tous la même chose
vous rendez pas compte en fait ça le
problème
genre pour vous un exemple j'en ai déjà
parlé la dernière fois
mais on est d'accord que vlad connaît
mieux les ouvertures que mathieu c'est
sûr il est encore un peu au dessus
mathieu il est déjà très haut mais vlad
il est encore au dessus
ça jusque là j'espère qu'on est tous
d'accord ça c'est sûr il a été second
dans pendant longtemps de great choqué
les seconds en de pas mal de très bons
joueurs pas dire de nom kouame vlad il
est vraiment hyper réputé
jusque là on est tous d'accord
j'ai demandé à vlad genre quand tu
parles ouverture avec great chioukh ckoi
à peu près votre niveau en fait ils
considèrent que great loong connantre
dix fois et 100 fois plus que lui donc
c'est à dire que l'écart entre invs la
dinguerie tchouk et d'un ratio entre 10
et 100 en gros de culture globale cc
c'est juste pour vous imaginez en fait
c'est fait c'est juste pour cesser ces
jus stratosphérique en fait faut
comprendre que les gars sont arrivés à
un niveau en fait vous n'imaginez même
pas en fait
c'est
ce fait à un moment donné le niveau en
fait limmex c'est incroyable en fait ce
qu'ils font pour être plus fort c'est
exponentiel c'est un truc de malade en
fait c'est pour ça des fois ya des
questions qui peuvent paraître bizarre
ou qui peuvent un petit peu énervé parce
que les gars en fait c'est si vous avez
l'impression que moi je suis fort par
exemple eux ils sont dix mille fois plus
fort que moi en fait
c'est n'importe quoi en fait leur niveau
leur intelligence leur vitesse de calcul
leur mémoire leur connaissance c'est
n'importe quoi
c'est juste n'importe quoi
ce etc juge choquant fait à quel point
ces gars réfléchissent vite pense vite
calcul vite
great chioukhs et maxime pour bien
connaître les deux vous pouvez parler de
n'importe quel sujet avec vous qu'avec
eux et vous surclassant fait fait faut
imaginer ça c'est en fait vous discuté
avec maxime il est tellement intelligent
qui se met à votre niveau en fait c'est
n'importe quoi en fait mais vous rendez
pas compte c'est juste vous rendez
réellement pas content et j'ai eu la
même impression et je connais très bien
gris tout qu'on est potes on est on a
souvent sorti ensemble avec sacha quand
avec lui tu as un coup en fait voyez
d'habitude vous êtes dans la vie de tous
les jours il ya des gens qui vous
paraissent un peu simple et ça peut
arriver il ya des gens du fonds à des
conversations il ya des groupes ya des
gens via tient lui il a un peu simplet
va en fait pour des gens comme maxime
grille tout coup quoi les simples et
c'est nous en fait foi les cons les gens
qui sont cons qu'ils pensent
qui pense lentement en fait ces gens
comme nous pour eux il faut que vous
compreniez en fait c'est pas ils ont pas
le même cerveau c'est pas assez parlé
même chose en fait c'est des gens
exceptionnels c'est une autre galaxie
ça en fait
et c'est incroyable en fait
c'est l'heure à leur vitesse de la
vitesse à laquelle il réfléchit c'est
juste impressionnante c'est
impressionnant fait
c'est impressionnant
ils réfléchissent réellement extrêmement
vite
c'est incroyable
après ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont
forcément cultivés sur beaucoup de
sujets où ça veut pas dire ça ça veut
juste dire que leur vitesse de penser la
vitesse à laquelle y penser
impressionnante après ce pas dire qu'ils
soient cultivés qui utilisent cette
intelligence à autre chose que de faire
des échecs ou quoi que ce soit
mais intrinsèquement en fait la vitesse
à laquelle il réfléchit c'est souvent
assez incroyable
magnifique les échecs malheur mémoire
généralement est impressionnante avec
maxime et gris tchouk souvent si tu as
parlé d'un truc avec eux qui s'est passé
un truc dans une soirée où quoi ils vont
s'en rappeler alors que toi tu vas où tu
vas oublier plus de choses que
et et si à un moment donné il ya des
questions qui se posent et qu'il faut
résoudre des petits problèmes ils vont
les résoudre c'est systématiquement
beaucoup plus vite
et pour tous ces petits trucs qui vont
être incroyable en fait
tafer un exemple je connais bien en
maths série glee yannick médaille fields
dès qu'il sort des maths il est
intelligent mais déclaré en politique
n'est pas tant que ça au dessus de la
mêlée
et mais la politique c'est plus de la
science sociale
c'est pas du tout un contre exemple
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est tant
que tu parle d'intelligence de mémoire
pour calculer des choses ils sont très
bon après si tu commences à parler de
littérature de musique ou de ou de
sciences sociales c'est pas du tout sûr
qu'ils aient une bonne compréhension du
truc
mais tout ce qui va avoir
toutes les capacités qui sont
utilisables aux échecs et s'ils sont
transposables dans le domaine de la vie
vont être impressionnant en fait
d'aider que ça va des ducs ou s'il faut
se rappeler de quelque chose et que ça
fait appel à la mémoire leur mémoire va
juste être hallucinante
globalement
et ans et en vrai ils vont calculer très
vite
il peut y avoir des trucs très bizarre
genre par exemple vlad
il va avoir fait que lors une nouvelle
force qui va juste pas vouloir essayer
de se rappeler mais s'ils essayent sa
mémoire est incroyable aussi bader ça se
voit quand vlad passé qui parle
d'histoire il est incroyable quand des
sujets d'intérêt c'est incroyable la
culture qui peut avoir
avec 15 15 3 me le code de ma porte il
n'a jamais voulu la prendre mais
messi il est sur des sujets qui
l'intéressent qui commencent à lire des
choses etc il va être absolument
impressionnant
ces chaudes d'anecdotes de ta porte je
tenais mon ancienne adresse c'est pas ma
porte chez moi actuellement
mais non ils sont incroyables
or ces échecs qu'a soir fait un gros
complotistes sur des trucs débiles
aller là encore ça de ces on sort on
sort de ce dont je parlais
vitesse de calcul et mémoire ces îles
sont impressionnants sur ces sujets là
incroyable
enfin bon tout ça pour dire que
ces joueurs sont incroyables et il faut
pas penser que
et il faut pas penser que que les
fichiers qu'ils ingurgitent que les
choses dont il sera pas aller tout ce
soit soit quelque chose qui soit normal
pour le commun des mortels en fait
c'est
ce serait vraiment impossible pour nous
de d'ingurgiter autant de
autant de matériel et de choses qui le
font
donc fabiano qui j'ai l'impression
trouve toutes les pros toute la première
ligne en fait
est
qu'est ce qui peut faire x 5 france et 7
pour cavaliers des deux qui est c4est
domination alors ça c'est une vraie
question
alors c'est ce que c'est pas juste gros
avantage blanc en fait
je suis complètement con
tous les jours
c'est que ces gens-là gmail badge leur
domaine mais ça fait pas d'eux forçant
les gens qui comprennent le monde c'est
exactement ce que je disais mirc
que dans l'école et donc que dans les
domaines d'intelligence qu'iliad on a
besoin pour jouer aux échecs qui sont
juste incroyables en fait
pas exactement une conclusion que même
et unique scène faire terrible
fabien olicard qu'une 7000 décimales de
pi non mais c'est rien en fait de
connaître 7000 décimales de pi par
rapport à ce qu'ils connaissent
vous n'imaginez pas en fait c'est ça le
truc
vous n'imaginez pas
c'est vous n'imaginez pas à quel point
c'est difficile
même 70000 décimales ses fins
n'imaginez pas ce que c'est
genre fabiano tout ce qu'ils connaissent
et c'est n'importe quoi en fait
c'est hallucinant
cfa soit en fait raconté que des fois il
devait s'y nettoyer la mémoire sinon il
explose et ouais c'est un truc de fou en
fait
on je me demande c'est pas bien pour les
blancs
vraiment dur tout ce qu'ils avalent tout
ce qu'ils ont à apprendre
décès souffrance et cette dame prend 6,7
j'adore les blancs j'adore les blancs
vrai
k
la sq est dur en plus dans tout ce que
tu dois apprendre c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de nuances la difficulté
d'apprendre toutes ces ouvertures c'est
que
s'ils pions et orage passé une chose si
le pion h2 faut jouer autre chose c'est
hyper compliqué en fait
c'est vraiment très compliqué
pourquoi les blancs pas un vrai avantage
ici
il serait pas mieux
il faut connaître tout il faut
comprendre les nuances si c'est vrai
c'est vraiment très complexe
tu expliques que des mecs qui sont des
produits extrêmement jeunes qui ne
connaissent pas forcément tous sont
extrêmes aux échecs a priori non pas une
marque c'est chiant ils ont un instinct
qui seront développés n'ont pas le temps
d'apprendre tout ce qu'elles veulent ou
carrément pu apprendre mais ils sont
moins forts aussi
wissmann ils sont un fort les jeunes
ils sont moins forts c'est pour ça
la lisère elle fait quoi je sais pas
encore
je sais pas seulement qu'on n'est pas
passé pour le moment c'est une partie
d'attentes alireza mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait pas les quarts
il m'inquiète un peu ali reza à vrai
dire on va rester sur la partie de
fabiano
associations se passe aussi pour y
réfléchisse autant on va de le truc
c'est que
là ils connaissent plus déjà et que même
si tu connais en fait ya tellement de
choses à connaître qui reconstruisent
dans leur esprit les leurs connaissances
généralement en fait à des points de
repère dans les fichiers tulle et
reconstruit
je voulais en arriver jusque là mais
comme
comme le chat était un peu en fait mais
on va pouvoir y revenir mais en fait ya
tellement de choses à connaître
et je voulais en arrive à ça c'est qu'en
fait ils ont des bisons de genre de
point de repère dans les fichiers il se
rappelle des évaluations il se rappelle
de certains coûts de certaines choses et
après ils reconstruisent les trucs quand
ils sont devant la partie c'est pour ça
que parfois vous les voyez réfléchir un
certain moment avant de jouer un coup et
vous à s'y connait pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils le jouent pas tempo whisky joue
pas directement mais c'est parce qu'en
fait ils recréent le fichier dans leur
tête nue un genre de checkpoint en fait
ouais
il ya un genre de schéma aider
et ils ont des points de repère des
évaluations dont ils se rappellent ils
peuvent même se rappeler d'un coup
précis et en fait ils recréent le truc
en fait
c'est le genre de temps de chargement
exactement
ça
as tu eu un truc démontrerait un truc
admis en cours de route pour être sûr de
lui mais en quelque sorte ouais
ils ont le résultat de la formule et ils
réécrivent la formule ou genre de choses
mais
si tu enlèves l'état met à cette
position c'est gagnant pour max en fait
j'adorerais jouer ça avec les blancs je
me sentirais tellement bien donc je sais
que les vals est pas énorme vous m'aviez
dit qu'il valait a5a et c7 c'était le
coup
l'auriez-vous à cinq et il va y avoir
d'amener cette france et 7 c sur mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est une telle
poussette s'est-elle tel prépa
j'ai une question à laquelle vous avez
vraiment un échiquier dans vos têtes et
pièces bouge une suite de chiffres et de
lettres je pense ça dépend ça dépend
généralement déjà quand on a mieux joué
alain wagon mais un échiquier devant
nous pour la voir visuellement mais
ouais je sais pas c'est un truc bizarre
je vois pas les jeux pour un perso si je
ferme les yeux je vois pas vraiment
l'échiquier à proprement dire mais je
sais pas j'ai pas trop comment ça j'ai
du mal à expliquer comment ça se
visualise il ya des gens qui les
visualise mieux que d'autres c'est ça va
dépendre de tout un chacun
mais genre si là par exemple je vois
d'amd cette souffrance et cette dame
français 7 qui est des deux en fait
clairement joué à la dame ans et 7 et le
cavalier en d2 ça ne pose pas problème
en fait j'ai pensé jordan 17 ita plage
faire crisser cas du coup il aurait
peut-être dame prend des cinq ce serais
plus protégée j'ai pas vraiment
découvert ce que madame en rade est pas
protégé va les protéger par la tour mais
je vais par là que je peux pas mettre un
échec
va dire que ça me demande pas un réel
effort de mettre la dame ans et 7 dans
ma tête et le cavalier ans et 4 mois
ça se fait un peu tout seul quoi d'amd
sajoo et france est en fait la partie
est très linéaire fait tous les coups
sont logiques fait ya quelques coups
importants comme le fou ici c'est le
cavalier à 6 mais tout le reste est
hyper logique
j'adore les blancs mais je sais pas
j'ai vu dans un reportage des pros
pouvait perdre jusqu'à 6000 calories par
jour pas mal et je crois que les
l'étude est ce qui a été fait de manière
inexacte et malheureusement plusieurs
parce qu'en fait ils ont mis des
capteurs
et cardiaque sur les joueurs et ils ont
interprété les statistiques comme si
c'était du sport comme s'il avait ce
nombre de battements de coeur à cause
d'une activité sportive alors que c'est
juste à cause du stress et de la
concentration
donc qui semble que ce soit une
expérience
ce dossier anti fille qui est mal été
réalisé qui a été récupéré par tous
va pas dire que c'est faux mais ça veut
dire que ça pas été prouvé de manière
exacte
c'est faux je dire que
c'est encore préparait là c'est encore
préparés
moi j'aime bien les blancs en bas il ya
un fou un set qui est bloqué derrière
les pions
et il ya un cavalier qui va jump en c4
qui va aller chercher les pions qui va
attaquer qui va faire du cavalier c4 qui
va envoyer une tour en a 7 où 1 à 6 une
dame en a quatre j'adore les blancs
je suis sûr que leur dis vous donne des
petites et vale
mais j'ai l'impression que je vais la
gagner salle avec les blancs
et c'est qu'à cette option étant prises
ok mais il faut voir risque d'amener
cette tour à cette dame b2
dame b 2 tours b2g cavaliers c4
j'attaque et j'encaisse là
donc ça veut dire que sur damas sept
tours à cette tape adam b2 auxerre fait
à que damas quatre pour chose pour
toucher le cavale a et j'ai pas cavalier
c4 ok je fais tourner un tas toujours
pas d'un b2g bouffe bouffe sari bouffe
donc tu dois jouer encore un coup ils
ont tous reçu 8 et cavaliers ces quatre
fois fuite mais ok ça on va la jouer je
te rassure un mais ça on va gagner en
fait
c'est le genre gagner avec les blancs et
c'est ce que veut avoir maxime et il en
est très proche
ok peut-être que l'ordi trouvant un truc
pour défendre mais pour un être humain
c'est très difficile fabiano dans la
sauce
c'est la sauce
difficile
ça a l'air vraiment difficile
lassé à 0 0 1 0 2 les vals la lacc c'est
vraiment un avantage blanc après ces
patients soit gagnant bien évidemment
mais ces avantages là c'est sur ces
positions agréable sans risque
ça c'est chiant à jouer c'est sûr
ça c'est évident le fou le fou à 8 à 0 à
venir le cavalier vient en c4 on alla
colonna
c'est dur
vraiment le cas c'est cissé confort je
suis pas sûr que le cavaliere et on sait
six personnes en c4 il manière très bien
ils couvrent b2 il tape des six
passé qu'un an le 4 en fait il peut être
touché alors le pion en c4 il est plus
jamais touché
non là magnifique la position est
magnifique
entourage auraient de position comme ça
atteint loin tu me donnes ça je suis
l'homme le plus heureux du monde avec
les blancs
après peut-être ça tient aux échecs il
ya tellement de choses qui tiennent
mais tu me donnes ça je suis l'homme le
plus heureux du monde
dames
b737 dam des cas d'accord
la farine en sf 5 4 peut-être qu'ils
doivent ne rien faire peut-être qu'en
voulant rien c'est pas si grave et oui
qu'un jour tu peux envoyer à 25,4 mail
5,4 ça paraît optimiste m
et a fait retour à 7 avec l'idée de
toucher le fouet sur dame b2 qui touche
le cavalier changer et faire cavaler c4
donc il va à jouer probablement dam des
quatre touchés le cheval
autour des 1 pour le protéger et tour f
1 8 août à mach 4
peut-être d'un mach 4 c'est peut-être ça
son idée
pour sûr car et les c4 avoir passé la
dame de l'autre côté et essayer de jouer
à eux quatre pour déstabiliser le cheval
peut-être mais bon
j'aime beaucoup les blancs quoi qu'il en
soit
ce que je draw se positionne seconde
famille non je vais quand même un petit
peu la jouer
non là je vais la jouer un peu
tête retour eux devraient pts à tours 2
aussi possible
là tu m'aimes meyers empêche le 4
il ya un peu moins de tours 1 mais ça
empêche 4
aucun espoir gens-là n'ont atteint aucun
risque est fait que pousser là
sur tours à cette dame b 4 tours 2 il ya
dame prend b2 pascal picq et ses quatre
oui mais du coup il ya ton concept ya
plutôt reprend des deux aussi
un super que là il ya tour à 8 vrai nom
message il
s'agit crois pas une seconde même pas
envie de regarder
car tu bouffes des six
c'est vrai les pubs on a oublié les pubs
les gars heureusement que vous êtes là
j'étais pas bien je suis complètement
happé par la partie quoi
je suis complètement happé par la partie
c'est trop intéressant en fait
c'est beaucoup trop intéressant
ouais
à partir est vraiment beaucoup trop
intéressante
pour ne pas pour ne pas mettre une
petite pub
terrible
on peut pas on peut pas on peut pas
subsister sans pub ici
trop dur
du coup ça gagne pas la pièce est ce que
b 4 et un coup
si on prend des quatre tours à 7
ça peut être une idée hein
ça peut être une vraie idée ça
dure évaluer
et quattro c'est intéressant comme coup
ça c'est une idée de marloux
ça c'est un coup de marloux
par fo qui on est plus près du micro
on peut aussi augmenter le son a
1 concernant la irréfléchie la la il
connaît plus
sur le stream moyen de pub ouais ça ça
m'étonne pas cela de la taupe en fait il
doit mettre une quantité de pubs
j'imagine les gens qui regardent plus
ils doivent en avoir autant mais plus
plus dissipés en fait
là c'est clair que c'est le premier
coureur prépa
c'est sûr que c'est le premier réparé
les amis
kiev avait un nom qui revient le temps
c'est quoi ces 43 minutes mais on a déjà
joué 25 coups
ça après ses dépositions
théorique à longtemps donc le design ne
sera peut-être pas trop grave
et well à contresens
j'avais envie d'aller le voir de toutes
façons
jeté un justin et la cam horrifié rouge
à
position est très tendue
il ya encore toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier
c'est complexe personne n'a pris le
dessus dans cette partie échiquier
3c qui a ré s'est vite yougov au part in
c'est hyper chaud aussi
hey you
contre shirov c'est chaud elle sous le
monde veut gagner de façon là c'est
tendu
et j'ai prévu de prendre ton progresser
et me demander jusqu'à quel âge ils
devraient pour accompagner à mon bouquin
jusqu'à 1100 1200 apprête à l'abonnement
de chaises comme qui peut être sympa
avec les deux les deux sont
complémentaires l'abonnement chess comme
ta 125 vidéos de leçons qui sont faites
pour les débutants pour progresser de du
début jusqu'à 1400 1500 et puis après
tatoue pas tout un tas de
d'outils supplémentaires pour progresser
les entraîneurs tactique les puzzles
rejeta plein de vidéos et de cours sur
une multitude de sujets assez incroyable
donc tu as aussi l'option de prendre
l'abonnement diamant l'essayer un mois
ou deux et voir à voir si ça plait quoi
pas les deux pas les deux choses qui
sont sympas
ouais on voit pas la colonne h exclut la
peu importe se passait pas grand chose
d'intéressant
région la coalition à 152 km j'irais
bien sûr touraine choqués qu'ils versent
les 500 seulement vrai
ça ce serait cool
wally les grands aux siens howell shirov
ça pourrait être une belle partie
à
souvent j'ai pesé le pour progresser je
stagne enfin à 1300 obligé galère un peu
contre des ouvertures que je connais pas
ah bah oui faire la tactique en fait
c'est votre plus grand problème
jusqu'à un certain niveau donc si vous
regardez déjà les vidéos que vous suivez
un peu vous devez avoir un bagage
stratégique quand même intéressant et il
faut se pâment de la tactique pour
progresser il faut faire les deux
vail dans le mal
non pas vraiment c'est le premier moment
où il réfléchit de la partie en vrai où
ils essayent plus de reconstruire le
fichier c'est le premier moment où il
réfléchit par lui même il a la position
qu'ils étaient venus chercher
mon taxi has come par jour tu peux faire
une demi heure tous les jours c'est déjà
pas mal tu peux faire plus tant mieux ne
te prive pas surtout
le problème c'est rue du matériel en
lien avec nos ouvertures la
quasi-totalité nos coûts fait sont très
utiles mais ne sont pas forcément nos
positions ah ouais mais en fait ce truc
c'est qu'il faut connaître toutes les
positions donc
cela répertoire d'ouvertures et puis
après tu
apprends petit à petit quoi
on apprend petit à petit
ça a quelque chose à apprendre par coeur
des séquences de coûts en plus
d'entraînement tactique non vraiment
apprenez les principes
apprenez les principes j'ai fait un
petit speedrun fois j'ai commencé un
speedrun sur ma chaîne facile tu peux
regarder un petit peu ce que je mets en
place pour monter jusqu'à 1100 1200
c'est pas très compliqué et ça suffit
pas besoin de connaître d'ouverture à
proprement parler faut juste connaître
quelques principes
est ce que tu veux quand je veux contre
le redoux contre des joueurs à petit
niveau moi je préfère jouer contre des
joueurs à tous les jeux après c'est une
question de goût mais je pensais plus
intéressant de jouer contre des joueurs
on sait les poteaux classique où tous
les puzzles rush les 2 1 moi je peux
plus puzzle classique mais les deux
peuvent être intéressant
c'est qu'elle finisse en relative et
2004 sans problème je pensais me de
s'entraîner à faire des puzzles niveau
mille cinq cent mille 100 à nant le
niveau des puzzles et complètement
décorrélée
donc ne vous occupez pas de votre lots
réellement puzzle juste essayer de
progresser au maximum
j'ai une question vaut mieux s'acharner
sur une tactique italie passé 20 minutes
ou s'obliger à passer si on n'a pas
trouvé non faut mieux s'acharner au
moins 10 minutes
je pense avoir une prime plus élevée non
mais le niveau de problème en fait c'est
complètement décorrélée enfin je connais
plein de gens à 1300 à 1400 qui ont des
lots supérieurs à 2000 ans problème un
neveu de 6 ans trop tôt pour lui
présenter le jeu
moi je pense qu déjà apprendre les
échecs à trois ans ou quatre ans après
ça dépend tout un chacun
je pense qu'à 3 4 ans
enfant si il a une capacité de conte de
concentration suffisante il peut déjà
apprendre à jouer aux échecs en fait
ouais ça dépend comment on fait les
puzzles sur czech comme c'est hyper
biaisé
parce qu'elle jusqu'au bout ce pas la
même histoire abri sûr que c'est biaisé
de bien les féroiens
j'ai appris à 80 avec mon frère après
faut pas le forcer sinon ça dégoûte
c'est ça ouais c'est pas vraiment une
question d'âge à partir de 3 4 ans tu
peut déjà prendre mais il faut qu'ils
aient l'envi la concentration etc 1
de l'enfant est certain à 7 8 ans ils
auront ils auront du mal encore à rester
concentrés ils n'auront pas l' envie de
faire ça et d'autres à 3 4 ans ils
pourront un
don qu'il a joués torah cette max j'ai
bien l'impression qu'il va y avoir d'amd
ça c'était tempo c'est sûr c'était fort
ces voiliers fabiano qui essaye de jouer
vite quand c'est des coups forcé qui les
a pas ce qu'il voit aujourd'hui qu'il
est moins bien autant qu'hier
et il prend un peu moins le temps en
fait là il a accéléré fabiano
moi je commençais à quel âge je vais
commencer à six ans et demi je pense six
ans et demi sept ans
parce que c'est un leurre plus des lots
en dix minutes quand 5 ouais c'est
normal aussi
calcul encore quand il se lève de
chicago il se vide l'esprit généralement
si la position est complexe tu calcules
si tu peux te permettre une vie de
l'esprit mais je pense que la i calcul
le pas clairac mon fils les avait à
trois ans ce niveau de concentration
requise ne les lis pas tout l'échiquier
à la fois ça c'est normal hein
reviens pas mieux moi j'aurais fait tour
d un plutôt que tours de main après tour
de il ya aussi l'argument de rester sur
la colonne
plutôt fait tour d un pur pour avoir du
tourin dans le règne plus tard mes tours
2 c'est aussi logique tu restes sur la
colonne tu couvres la deuxième et tu es
tu as déjà joué à troyes pour éviter le
mag du couloir favret dira peut-être
j'aurai je suis reparti pour tour de au
final
ce qui a empêché de caronna de prendre
le pion
c'est que surprise du pion prise du pion
prise du pion il tapait le cavalier ça
permettait de reprendre mais avec
cavaliers c4 qui retape et la tour et ap
le fou
du coup il a décidé de jouer dans b4
comme ça surtout reprend 1,7 et adam
prend des deux
j'ai problème on sait qu'il ya quelque
chose à travers qu'en partie on sait pas
forcément
ouais mais si tu es très bon en tactique
tu trouve en partie aussi en fait
j'ai commencé à prendre plutôt qu'à si
tu penses que tu aurais une plus grande
prudence est révolu d'évolution non je
crois que c'est pareil commence à trois
ans aux six ans soit pas que ça change
grand chose
et coupez les lives et la corne à la fin
de l'eau douce on sait d'où elle vient
ce serait beau mais de l'empêcher de
voir
s qui a cavalé c4 ici prennent que les
c4 ces dames prendre
petite question dans les grosses
préparer ce que regardent les avale
d'ordi serait pas plus intéressant pour
juger la position je suis partisan de la
position mais à quel point max et bien
non
de toute façon si c'est encore la prépa
et qu'ils connaissent bien c'est que les
vannes au final c'est 000 ça on le sait
tous
si tous les coups sont mijn ça va
jusqu'à nul ça on le sait
donc ya pas besoin de regarder les
valent pour savoir que c'est autre chose
que 000
mais le truc c'est de comprendre à quel
point
à quai c'est dur ou pas
c'est 00 soit la turbine est capable de
prouesses pas 0-0 et concentré pas en
gros c'est ça souvent
il ya l'iresa ali reza qui est une
partie difficile on est passés le voir
plusieurs fois pour le moment il réussit
pas à se débarrasser de howell ils sont
dans une partie tendue avec toutes les
pièces sur l'échiquier
on va voir si ali reza réussi à faire
vaciller le joueur britannique
il n'y a pas de prébende fils pas un
piège forcé
alors niveau non ya pas de prépa qui
gagne à coup sûr avec les blancs
ça existait en fait les blancs gagnera
tous les coûts donc non meilleur coup
noir va toujours donné égalité donc il
peut pas y avoir de prépa qui gagne à
moins que l'adversaire se trompe mais
sinon c'est pas possible
il a joué maxime ou pas je le vois
écrire quelque chose
un jeu parfait mais n'allez nulle louis
toi tu sais pas certains savent doba
kyste on a déjà
des technologies qui nous permettent de
savoir que je parfait mannala nul
mais jeu parfait est impossible
comme ça ouais
mais n'est pas loin d'être bien mais
dont qu'on avait d1 et d'un mach 4 ici
qui semblait intéressant
j'aime beaucoup les blancs mais bon
j'aime beaucoup les blancs
regardez mine de turbine est
ok mais genre ce genre de lyndon 00 mais
en fait il ya personne qui va faire ça
alors ça alors zidane 00
menaces matif et tours 1 et il fait
perpète
et du coup d'euros pour vous dire que ok
peut-être que c'est nul parce qu'à ce
genre de ligne mais il faut les trouver
après dans la chasse à quoi changer
trois mais je pense que
tu décale simplement ta dam de la tuque
allant h cinq touchés ici peut-être et
sur g4 venir en h4 et tu vas avoir f5
tués attaqués loi
c'est moins qu'en jeu par le service y
avait quelqu'un en train de gagner c'est
fou ça c'est un nouveau plus haut qui
revient quoi
je viens après je commente le tournage
vient après
comédienne hamel alors là on regarde les
parties de maxime et on est dans un plus
tard l'ina on va pas on va pas faire des
cartons quoi ça et on fait par l'iphone
boxing quoi
sur un live boxing quoi la patronne
la patronne
en fera près il n'atteint kg est pas
mais les choses dans les cartons
regarderaprès pas de soucis
patronne aide
fatima patronne aide
la patronne qui vient c'est la patronne
on n'est pas bien
la patronne qui est venu sévir
faye elle est vraie
patronne aide
qui l'a fait tourner à
cet effet ses patrons avant patronnait
dont on va toujours un la patronne
avec pour ce soir ouais
bah je crois que mon set up streaming je
suis pas sûr qu'ils fassent le
déménagement
joueur d'échecs joseph la patronne on
ne perd pas son temps avec des choses
aussi inutile
il a fait quoi famille pas vu le coup il
a joué tempo n'ont
donc tour d un tueur bessette hockey
servi cas ce qu'indique sont dans la
vraie vie c'est quand ta femme te dit
chérie fais comme tu veux c'est toi qui
vois ah oui mais ça c'est terrible c'est
pas bien donc tomber ça est ok
cavaliers c'est quattro bouffe
j'adore les blancs mais bon
ok c'est sur des trucs tactique en fait
en fait ils jouent tactiquement sur le
pion détroit
qui essaient quatre gros avantage blanc
tampon à cette dame prend à cette dame b
tours 1 du coup
dame prend des trois dames procède d'un
français quatre dames prend des six
dames des cats assez gros avantage
mandat prévost turbines
fabry raconte n'importe quoi dans le
châtier c4 ça a pas l'air
ça a pas l'air mauvais mais ça a l'air
de demander pub après un
clairement sa demande pub
e
mais tout reprend tout reprendre la main
b 3 tours d2 il ya fou g5 et toi
dam des trois jeux disait vrai vous
n'êtes pas le coup numéro on leur dit
par contre
ça salaire proche de droit quand même
parce que tour c'est un genre
g6 dame prend
pour des huit dames prend pions prend
pour ses cinq tours b 8 et même s'ils
ont réussi à faire ça
ça doit être drôle
ça pedro
tendu un
fabiano en train de jouer une partie
incroyable franchement fabi en train de
faire une partie gigantesque
il est vraiment en train de faire une
partie énorme le joueur américain
attention parce que j'ai des primes de
file
avec les trucs attention on est là là là
on peut on peut se faire dès ce que
déconnecté on n'est pas bien les gars
on est on est vraiment pas bien on est
on est dans le très dur là haut ce live
ce live pourrait sauter à tout moment
voilà j'ai en plus j'ai des plages et
l'ordi qui bug gelant sueur
un problème carte graphique en fait je
sais pas pourquoi d'affichage
j'espère que s'améliorer
on risque de par la connexion et non en
fait j'ai eu un problème de branchement
au tout début sur l'écran qui s'est un
peu débranché mon peu importe
si on pas vraiment
célébrer mais pas des problèmes hardware
c'est
c'est le fils de l'écran qui sait
débrancher un peu plus tôt
on peut importe
de carhaix et de max
sert à rien
enfin pas vraiment il va venir en c4
d'ailleurs il y est venu non
ok ça a été un truc très fort c'est
s'est tendu
qui avait laissé quatre jouer way
cette dame prend à cette dame b 3 tours
1 dame prend des trois saints paraître
à rien de voir si j'arrive pas à évaluer
ça en fait
pas si quelqu'un peut passer ça sur une
grosse turbine j'arrive pas à l'évaluer
ou en tout cas cette variante en gros
à la mama turbinait mais si
elle est dans mon nouveau studio déjà
elle a déménagé avant
ce qui parle d'une une msi qui parler
mais je reste que ce truc là c'est
vraiment cette variante là parce que
c'est la plus linéaire la plus directe
lors cette position là on va dire
genre 7,7 cette position précise que ça
là on peut l'avoir en force
si ça c'est égal s'inquiétant
on fabiano en train de réaliser juste la
partie parfaite en fait c'est incroyable
ce que fait fabiano on ne le dit pas
assez on ne le dit pas assez maxime qui
sort une grosse partie mais là fabiano
il joua
en fait fabiano jouer au niveau 2
l'ordinateur dans cette partie
pour le moment serre que maxime duplass
prépa et fabiano est juste en train de
jouer la partie parfaite honnêtement il
n'y a pas une seule faute une seule
imprécisions rien en fait
c'est
c'est le fabiano pour le moment ni vos
matches championnat du monde contre carl
scène sauf qu'à un moment donné en tout
cas là ce qu'il est en train de te faire
c'est juste une partie où il ya personne
au monde qui peut le battre
tu peux rien faire là pour le moment
maxime il fait sa partie joue bien mais
il ne peut rien faire pour le moment il
n'a pas d'ouverture fabiano est juste en
train de jouer la partie parfaite
peut-être un mur de thé nul qui peut
partir un
peut-être un mur de thé nul peut être
content que le thé nul à et on tente on
tente le mur de thé nul
le mur de thé nul qui part à la il faut
mettre que des émaux temps là ceux qui
n'ont pas les émeutes il faut pas écrire
tu es nul il faut tenter le mur
à m
tu être notre seule chance que là ce
qu'il est en train de faire fabiano
c'est extraordinaire
ce cas pour le moment réellement ils
jouent ils jouent tous les coups
parfaits juste où les coups parfaits
c'est assez incroyable il réussit à
évaluer les positions à comprendre
ce qui fait c'est vraiment
extraordinaire pour le mans fabiano
faire une partie comme ça de bout en
bout c'est quasiment impossible
donc il va bien finir par faire une
erreur un maximum et la pression depuis
un long moment quand même maintenant ça
fait une dizaine de coups que fabien ne
se trompe pas il va bien finir par faire
une couille as
et le mur de thé nul qui va lui faire
très mal là
ce mur fait à mon avis très mal à
fabiano
là le titan a merry talent et qui fait
mal pour le moment
mais le mur qui part et qui peut et qui
peut mettre à mal faby en sueur
et alireza on va les juges jeter un
petit à petit à yahoo elle comme ça il
se prend petit à petit mur de thé nul
dans la gueule aussi ça fait pas du bien
pollution est compliqué un côté howell
mon avis ça va finir par craquer côté
côté britannique
et que tu évites yougov au par in
c'est hyper chaud
ce serait pareil petite fille de fordo
par in quand même avec maxime au noir à
la dernière contre opa rinne ça peut
aller chercher là où il aussi attention
grégory
et jeu gears of harry krishna
hockey et shirov
shirov qui vont envoyer grand roque et
ça va être ça va être la guerre terrible
on a fait un petit tour on va retourner
sur maxime
on voit où elle en difficulté allez les
français
le double mur qui est parti
il est beau ce mur
magnifique
fabiano 38 minutes ça devrait lui
suffire il reste que 12 coups il a très
bien géré son temps elle pour le moment
il fait deux parties exemplaires 1
contre contre maxime et contre ali reza
il fait réellement deux parties
extraordinaire fabiano
pour le moment mais il va bien finir par
jouer un coup en dessous quand même il
peut pas nous jouer mainline tout le
long
sinon il va falloir faire une petite
fouille après la partie
et quand on parle de fouilles on sait
très bien de quoi on parle attention
fabiano ils s'exposent
ils s'exposent fabiano non il joue
vraiment bien c'est sûr qu'à pas de
problème injuste paquet de personne qui
puisse penser qu'ils aient une chance
qui est de la triche là c'est pas du
tout le cas
c'est juste que fabiano ben il a été
numéro 2 mondial pendant des années et
qu'il est capable
de sortir le grand jeu dans les grands
moments ce qu'il est en train de faire
actuellement
mais ce qu'il va s'arrêter de faire au
plus vite
allez c'est maintenant qu'il faut
craquer pour famille
ça réfléchit en tout cas
ça calcule
tout reproche et ça c'était plus ou
moins sûr c'est le coup d'après qui nous
intéresse entre guillemets parce que
tourcoing à cette dame prend 1,7 ça ça
va être joué et la voyez fable fabiano
ils ne se lève pas il sait que maxime va
revenir et comme il est un peu sous
pression autant il attend que maxime
reviennent il sait que dame prend 1,7 et
le prochain coup on s'efforçait et il va
probablement jouer tempo après dun
princesse il va probablement jouer tempo
pour conserver un maximum de temps il
veut pas se retrouver en direct note
face à maxime il sait que c'est
dangereux et donc ils se gardent un
petit matelas de sécurité
mais ça lui donne moins de moments de
récupération il va falloir avoir la
caisse côté italien
cassé intelligence qui fait il gère
vraiment très bien sa partie le joueur
le joueur italien et ça boit un petit
peu d'eau
sémalens qui fait
c'est un marc loup
alors maxime serait pas complètement
éliminé en cas de nul il y aurait quand
même encore une chance demain au noir or
à prendre tous les risques
mais maxime ne va pas
tenter un coup de bluff stupide
aujourd'hui il va essayer de mettre
pression le plus longtemps et le maxi le
maximum et le plus longtemps possible
mais il va pas s'entêter non plus il
préféra s'entêter demain contre un
joueur plus faibles ou là il devra
prendre tous les risques quitte à perdre
mais mais nulle et est encore un
résultat
sera un mauvais résultat un très
clairement mais on va pas faire exprès
exprès de perdre alors que là on a un
magnifique plan d'eau
extraordinaire
veste bien propre
voilà c'est magnifique ça nous bouge
bien la vue
un placement très opportun
ça nous empêche bien de voir les coups
joués pour la façon c'était dame prend à
7 et à mon avis vous allez voir fabiano
jouets tempo dame b3 et voilà c'est ça
tempo il a quasiment pas paris fléchit
ce que voulait maintenant il va se lever
probablement
non même pas il reste là
assis impassible fait il doit penser que
tours a en réalité forcé
à maxime peut vouloir jouer tourer avec
l'idée d'un prend des trois dames
prendre cette dame france et 4 dames
prendre ici c'est la tour et peut-être
bien placé sur le pion à donc tour 1 est
une option à toi peut-être malin en vrai
j'aime le coup à vrai dire
je pense qu'il va faire tout est en
réalité
maxime qui réfléchit
je pense qu'il va jouer tourer
comme ça il interdit il interdit
la finale
et ça c'est beaucoup plus chiant parce
que ça va être après fou des huit qui
est ronde et 6 dame prend des 5 et sa
garde un peu plus de jeu avec le
cavalier toujours supérieurs aux fous
mais bon ça s'approche quand même de
drouot nettement
ça reste petit poucet tu m'aimais
fabiano à donne l'impression d'être
sorti du plus compliqué
après comme je voulais aussi il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de coups à tours 1 qui
est joué par maxime
beaucoup de coups a
même joué par fabiano
et un moment donné il va bien finir par
glisser un parce que là la pression elle
est encore là on est encore au 30e coup
ça fait trente coups que tu fais pas
d'erreur fabiano alors après il y avait
on va dire 20 coûts d'ouverture mais ça
fait dix coupes fabiano joumine il joue
l'acier ce soir cet après midi plutôt
donc il peut jouer ici food et 8 sur
quoi maxime répondra peut-être par un
coup comme tours 3
à 3 pts est refoulé cinq
jours qui revient
pour bouger d'amd un fief 4
peut-être les cinq direct du coup il ya
des six dames des cinq
cavaliers eu 4
et h6 peut-être tu vas jouer quelque
chose comme ça
est ce que cette finale est gagnante
pour maxime ou pas
question
ça peut gagner ça le pion est bien placé
en dépasse qu'il est passé devant eux il
sera un peu moins bien
ça peut gagner
ça va être une une partie longue et
complexe
ça va être une partie longue et complexe
les amis
là c'est pas
panne on n'est pas dans le simple
c'est parti pour durer
donc là on est au 30e coup il reste dix
coups à jouer fait 20 ou 35 minutes il a
commencé à utiliser du temps à partir du
xvième et donc ça fait quatorze coups
parfaits consécutif
14 coup parfait consécutifs pour fabiano
c'est pas rien les amis joué quatorze
coups turbine
d'affilée c'est quand même en soi un
exploit
mais bon ils vivent c'est impossible de
continuer à jouer
à jouer meine pendant 20 25 30 40 50
coups en fait il ya un moment donné tu
es obligé de deux joué un peu en dessous
quoi c'est pas possible autrement
c'est juste pas humain sinon à faire
parler de feu y arriver mais c'est trop
quoi
il ya un moment donné
je vais mettre un tweet
on aimar pour moi un tweet
j'en vois un petit tweet le tweet qui
est parti
en voyant un petit tweet j'enlève les
mots tonnes lit je pense que le mur de
thé nul va faire son effet il faut le
laisser infuser maintenant
on voyage envoyé le petit tweet
féd 1 prend des 3
alors est ce que ce serait enfin la
faute dame prend des trois est ce que ce
serait enfin la photo est ce que c'est
drôle quand même dans procède d'un
prince et 4 d'un prend des six
est ce que ce serait pas être première
imprécisions qui part après le tweet ce
serait pas étonnant au ba oui oui on a
l'habitude aidant mais c'est peut-être
nul en fait ce truc là je sais pas
je sais pas ça peut être drôle comme ça
peut ne pas être trop
ça peut être drôle comme ça peut ne pas
être trop fait donc en gros je sais pas
ça aurait être plus un seul pas
forcément dire grand chose ça peut être
puissant dans un truc nul théorique
enfin c'est un ensemble mais d'amd
4g pas à quel point c'est nul ou gagnant
pour
j'essaie de regarder une ligne de
turbine est
l'ours à quel point c'est nul ou gagne
en j'en sais rien ces poussettes c'est
sûr
j'ai plus confiance aux joueurs plus
forts ici c'est complexe si fins
sexuelles mais du coup max ça me fera
jouer très longtemps
ouais ouais ça c'est sûr robin times à
quel point c'est grave ou pas ça parce
que peut-être que c'est facile à
défendre en vrai
zéro en profondeur 69 oh
ouais risque c'est dur à jouer ou pas
c'est la question
ce que la variante est assez fort c'est
moi je pense qu'il va craquer fabi
il s'est fait infuser tu es nul il s'est
pris le tweet ça en fait peut-être trop
pour un homme
un profondeur 26 ça veut rien dire
ça va rien dire
ce qu'il a dit est ce qui la tient pas
en fait c'est
non mesdames décade c'est sûr que celles
pour les noirs
j'ai passé difficile à juger bon
évidemment on prend les blancs tous les
jours
mais à quel point ses proches de gain ou
pas
d'âme des quatre dames prends ça ça
risque d'être nulle en fait
ça il ya de gros risques
tu veux garder les dames ici
mesdames les 400 g prend b2 pas possible
bien ça il faut voir si dame 7,17 décédé
six des sept des huit marche ou pas en
fait on va décider cette semaine et sera
d'un premier fils trois points fitouri
huit matches quand même alors si tu fais
ça en fait je fais pas d'âme dame en
même temps
gaza
dam des 4 5
h 6 dames cette tourbe et 8 il doit
essayer de s'activer
je pense qu'il va la gagner maxime celle
là
tout cas maxima pour le mans lui joue
tous les meilleurs coups aussi un maxime
il n'a pas joué un coup en dessous après
il avait beaucoup plus de fous dans la
prépa mais depuis la fin de la prépa il
joue pas un seul cours en dessous 1
aujourd'hui la page ou encore en dessous
maxime il a joué que les meilleurs coups
maintenant est-ce que ça va suffire ou
pas
4 jouer ça c'était sûr je suis même pas
sûr que le dame prend des trois de
fabiano était une erreur
si ça ça tient ses parties parfaites
toujours un
voir qui craqueraient à la place de
karwan à face à cette pression mais
fabiano
mesdames prend on comprend que ça va pas
le pion faut bien le bouffer du bouffey
avec la tour
et cheyrou déjà il en est où c'est une
excellente question
la partié ultra-complexes
un truc c'est qu'on peut pas on peut pas
s'y plonger
mais je pense qu'on va avoir un bonsaï
t-notes en prévision
donc ça va être sympa à suivre aussi
les deux français ont des bonnes
positions donc c'est assez rassurant
il s'est passé quoi chez maxim
ans la clim à la clim
f 6
6 tours des 8 et 6 3
7% à 3 et fluide cedro au la clim
au nom au nom
à la clim
la première erreur est venue de maxime
dans cette partie
il a raté chose
aux non
c'est pas possible
il a raté avis il a raté un truc [ __ ]
il jouait là il a joué la partie
parfaite jusqu'au 30 4e maxime c'est
maxime qui kakon premier
il a raté tout reprend
à
arrive le rat fabiano qui a quand même
sorti une partie énorme
à
terrible
il sait qu'il s'est trompé au [ __ ]
fabiano il sait qu'il a ça y est ils le
savent
ah ils le savent
ryle saft un temps reprend 1,5 c'était
hyper chaud
[ __ ] quelle partie de fabiano est
laissée plus fabiano qui sort une partie
énorme que maxime qui déjoue quand même
sur celle là
là quelle partie de fabiano aucune
erreur
mais vous parlez de maxime et vous
rendez pas compte de la perte de fabiano
en fait ça qui dégoûte avec le chat
c'est qu'en fait vous comprenez pas que
là la partie qui vient de faire caruana
c'est caruana niveau matches championnat
du monde contre carl scène en fait là il
a joué s'appelait partie de fabiano
contre ali rezaï contre maxime sait il a
rejoué son niveau numéro deux mondial en
fait il est juste plus fort c'est pas
une question de mental ou quoi que ce
soit c'est juste qu'il est plus fort
c'est incroyable ce café à fabiano dans
cette partie en vrai
c'est réellement incroyable
il a pas rist imax assuré sans arrêt à
perdre du temps est un peu comme
nepomniachi franquart ya un peu comme
nepomniachi qui se lave à tous les coups
et qui est pas du tout investi
énormément fin ça sont comme d'habitude
le chat va me saouler genre de donneurs
de leçons alors qu'eux ils se rendent
pas compte de comment c'est dur le
niveau qui ait joué là c'est savent ça
dégoûtant vrai ça me fait penser dès
qu'il ya des délais match de tennis les
machins le foot away machin il joue mal
va va courir sur le terrain va courir
comme ça dégoûtant vrai ça dégoûte ce
que la maxi fait sa partie des tampons
et 5 ça suffisait probablement pas mais
fabiano fait une partie incroyable
fabiano fait une partie juste incroyable
les amis
il faut souligner quand l'adversaire
joue bien
il a été il a vraiment été
exceptionnelle fabien aujourd'hui
c'est contre eux ali rezaï contre maxime
ccl2 loin ses deux meilleures parties
depuis
depuis très longtemps en réalité
ça fait très longtemps qu'il joue pas ce
niveau
il a reçu il a sorti son meilleur niveau
au moment le plus
le plus important enfin maxime e'lara
tf6 si le voit maintenant
il a dû rater quelque chose dans une
variante dans une ligne
et là il rien
et c'est un peu ça le point faible de
maxime quand même ils n'arrivent pas à
presser hillary défense est le meilleur
défenseur du circuit probablement un des
tous mes gars avec aria kiné il défend
de manière active ils ont deux défenses
différence mais il a une petite lacune
pour maintenir la pression très
longtemps comme le font car lé scène
caruana
et leïla il a lâché la pression avant
que avant en premier en fait
quel dommage quel dommage
bon c'est pas fini il peut encore gagner
demain le tournoi n'est pas terminé
encore pour maxime
et il nous reste alireza encore à suivre
quand même con tre howell partie très
importante aussi pour pour le deuxième
joueur franck point le premier numéro un
français en réalité
mais quelle partie de fabiano j'aimerais
bien quand même que
rendent hommage à ce
à sa partie à son niveau de jeu parce
que vu la prépa a vu la complexité du
truc
il a quand même sorti parce que je
considère que ce qu'il a fait c'est pas
vraiment une imprécision dame prend des
trois c'est juste une simplification
mais ça veut dire que de ce moment là en
fait fabiano donc à la sortie de la
prépa ne va pas faire une seule erreur
tous les coups que vous voyez de fabiano
sont toujours
soit coup un soin coup deux est en fait
c'est tout le temps meilleurs meilleurs
coups en réalité
et ben ouais quand le mec les 16
premiers coûte fabiano la sq il a joué
dans la théorie c'était bon et tout ce
qu'il a à jouer par la suite pour aller
chercher la drau c'est bon aussi donc ça
veut dire que fabiano il a réalisé
réellement une partie avec les noirs
avec laquelle il aurait pu alors après
s'il avait joué contre lord il aurait
fini par la perdre après tourcoing 5,1
après tout reprend 1,5 quand l'ordi de
finit toujours par perdre mais en
réalité jusque là tu aurais redonner la
main au noir un ordinateur il aurait
fait nul c'est à dire qu'il a joué 34
coups un niveau entre 3500 et 3600 lots
c'est juste incroyable en fait
et maxime aux siens de son côté c'est
pareil on se tait 3053 1005 et c'est
maxime qui craquent en premier et qui
joue le coup en dessous en premier
mais bon quand c'est comme ça et que la
première imprécisions de ta part tu y
arrives au 35e quoi avec les blancs
est ce que tu veux dire en fait
c'est et tu 3500 points en 35 ou tu fais
un coup en dessous fins et
on reconnaît le champion se sublimer le
jour j c'est exactement ça un
ambulancier la caruana c'est un grand
monsieur il est mal dans le tournoi il
va chercher une win incroyable contre
grand délice avec les noirs dans une
partie mais oui oui galère où il a du
mal il va vraiment la chercher au fond
de lui cette victoire derrière il va la
chercher au fond lui contre firoud déjà
hélas il te sort ça en défense les trois
dernières parties de karwan à ces trois
master class ces trois master class les
gars
la maxi et qui peut plus gagner mais ces
trois master class de fabiano géré au
bout d'un moment il faut aussi
s'incliner et dire bravo champion 1
il faut s'incliner devant un champion et
un joueur de grand talent qui éclabousse
de sa classe cette partie et cette fin
de tournoi
c saf cd beau échec aussi un c'est beau
ce que fait fabiano il faut aussi voir
la beauté du jeu et
la beauté de la performance du sportif
mais même même si j'ai envie de dire
ennemis d'un jour mais mais on est là
pour pour voir aussi ce genre de partie
l'espoir pour maxime basse et de jouer
contre un joueur qui doit le battre
demain avec les blancs et le contre et
maxime mais pas encore éliminés loin de
là
cas des candidats sankara ne s'est pas
la même le mec est très fort et très
classe non mais là ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui fabiano c'est incroyable
après demain il ya beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent arriver
si vous gagnez sera cet ennemi car on a
cette fois vraiment un énorme chance que
maxime se qualifie
nom maxime gagné
maxime ne peut faire huit points
enfin je sais pas classement en tête
mais si maxime gagne demain il peut
gagner chaque week-end j'ai juste fait
que max ait fait cette erreur dans le
sens où il apprit l'addition peut être
un peu vide et changer les dames
il a fait une erreur de calcul dans une
variante il a oublié un truc dans une
variante
bac celle ci sera sinueuse mois
peut-être fera cet ennemi fabiano il va
être il aura autant de points que
fabiano demain maxime où il a moins de
points que fabiano faut que j'aille
revoir les classements moi j'étais dans
la tête qu'il fallait qu'ils gagnent
aujourd'hui de base mais il n'est pas
complètement éliminé ça c'est sûr je
vais les voir les classements exact
en fait j'étais sur le truc que victoire
le mettait très bien
je sais que victoire le mettais très
bien mais là j'ai pu les classements
tête un jeu
maxime et a6 favy si ses ennemis
aouina effectivement alors il est très
mal
bien
mais il faudra quand même faire bonne
figure et tenter de tenter sa chance
jusqu'au bout
il reste six rounds j'allais gagne a pas
de on a deux français marne on n'en a
plus qu'un on en a plus qu'un et on en a
plus qu'un dans les deux sens du terme
du coup on va pouvoir quand même
continuer à y croire
il reste quoi
restait encore les grands prix feed
c'est pas pareil que maxime c'est vrai
qu'on a plus ça on a on a un côté
passionnel j'ai envie de dire avec
maxime mai mais le toit n'est pas
complètement complètement finie pour les
tricolores donc on va quand même essayer
de garder le sourire et si
avant le début du tournoi nous avait dit
qu'on aurait un français sur deux au
candidat on aurait signé tout de suite
donc on va quand même allez allez
supporter ali reza
mais là il tombe
il tombe sur un grand quart ouanna mais
j'ai envie de vous dire
firoud déjà hier il est tombé sur un
grand quart ouanna aussi on ne vous
entendez pas dire il n'a pas de mental
alireza nanani nanana
voici avec le
problème c'est qu'on va leur père de ce
pion
il va faire tour des huit
tours dé 6,3 et c'est jessy c'est tout
reprend on peut pas empêcher ça en fait
et si on fait des six il va faire tout
reprendre tout reprendre tour échec et
tours d2
elle aurait pu faire un plus de travail
avec les blancs en milieu de tournoi
non le seul regret de maxime dans ce
tournoi pour moi si on l'a le tournoi
n'est pas terminé mais en gros le moment
pour moi c'est pas du tout la 6e' un
moment où il perd entre guillemets le
tournoi c'est pas du tout là il ya il ya
deux choses déjà il n'a pas de bol de
commencer noir n'est pas commencée blanc
parce qu'ils se tapent six fois noir
cinq fois blanc et on voit que c'est
complètement déterminant donc déjà il ya
ça qui le
qui le met dans le dur en fait d'avoir
une fois de moins les blancs c'est ce
que ça a joué demi point près donc ça
c'est un premier est un premier pas de
bol eu du coup qu'il met en difficulté
un peu dès le début du tournoi ce qui
redouble jamais les blancs
et le deuxième moment
contre ça chie quirion peut-être fallait
un peu plus poussée ou contre shirov un
peu plus poussé la finale l'a peut-être
sur ces deux partis s'ils poussent les
deux il fait un demi point de plus et du
coup là nul aurait suffi ici
mais après on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de
réussite aussi un fil rouge à la partie
contre mayer honnêtement il prend un
cadeau c'est tant mieux il a un peu plus
poussé que maxime et ils le méritent ce
cadeau mais
mais on va dire qu'il ya un côté réussit
aussi et maxime il n'a pas forcément eu
la réussite tout au long avec lui après
la chance sourit aux audacieux et il n'a
pas été audacieux contre shirov est
contre et contre ce à shiki riant et
peut-être s'il avait été qui l'avait
poussé à fond ces deux parties il avait
une chance sur deux de prendre un demi
point de plus et donc d'être bien donc
mon avis si pour moi en tant que
spectateur s'il y avait un regret ce
serait sur ces deux parties de ne pas
avoir poussé
grey il est là mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui pour moi aujourd'hui a pas
de
ya pas de regret à avoir fabiano sort
une partie majuscule il ya peu de
personnes dans le monde qui aurait pu le
battre voire même personne je vous
rappelle que six parties avec les noirs
contre carl scène en match de
championnat du monde 0 défaites 1
caruana en longues c'est à dire que
quand caruana met les barbelés et qui
joue niveau max comme il joue comme il
joue top aujourd'hui car ce n y en a
pris 0,1 sur sur six parties donc faut
arrêter dire qu'arsène aurait gagné
matin car le sel il en a pas gagné une
contre caruana c'est ça repose les bases
donc rater pas battre caruana avec les
blancs dans une partie où joue comme ça
il n'y a pas à rougir enfin il ya
personne au monde qui peut le battre en
fait quand il joue comme ça il faut
sortir la partie parfaite il a pas
réussi à le faire mais d'un autre côté
ça c'est quasiment impossible en
revanche un sachet qui riant dans une
position un peu tendues avec les noirs
qui espère une nulle se jette sur ta
main et il reste douze minutes et est ce
que tu peux risquer comme six rounds jal
a fait contre eux vierge mais prendre le
risque de perdre peut-être contre shirov
on peut essayer de pousser la finale
personne n'avait compris qu'elle était
gagnante mais on attend aussi ce genre
de chose d'un top mondial mais cette
game là il n'y a rien à regretter y'a
pas à dire il n'a pas de mental ya pas
de machin du relais qui joue max qu'est
ce tu veux faire je répète toi je vous
met en face d'eux stockfisch 14 vous
allez perdre toutes les parties vous
n'avez pas de mental
c'est la scop glaçant
de carrick à la coupe du monde fabien g7
sera sauf alors qu'ariane chine a aussi
eu du bol dans la partie club où il sera
ce parce que les coûts qui jouent ils
prévoient pas en avance et même si ses
premières lignes toulon il a du bol que
ça passe la fabiano il a vraiment il est
en contrôle en plus
contre car iachini un côté cariat qu'ils
jouent bien et en plus maxime a pas de
bol il ya un peu les deux là sur cette
partie là c'est caruana ce sort une
partie exceptionnelle c'est tout
tout ça arrive qu est-ce qui tu es fier
en fait c'est un jeu où si tu joue
parfaitement tu peux pas gagner le mec
joue parfaitement tu veux faire quoi
et c'est difficile 1
raf il a noté que c'était le meilleur
choix mais c'est pas du tout vrai c'est
tellement pas vrai contre l'indien c'est
de la gestion de tournoi c'était un
choix vous le regrettez maintenant à
posteriori mais c'était un choix
maintenant on voit qu'il aurait
peut-être but +10 pc mais contre shirov
c'est plus cela qu'il a il avait une
bonne position il devait la pousser
contre shirov c'est plus cela qu'il
avait qu'il a eu un choc quoi
contre l'indien c'était un choix il se
trouve que ça n'a pas été le bon mais ça
aurait très bien pu être un bon choix il
a gardé de l'énergie et maintenant
contre voit la physionomie du tournoi on
se rend compte que l'erreur a été la
fario l'erreur qu'il aurait peut-être
fallu le faire on sait pas faim peut pas
savoir exactement messi a des regrets
ils sont là ils sont pas aujourd'hui
comme à l'école où vous donne une
réponse et vous avez les résultats pour
savoir si la réponse est bonne ou
mauvaise dans la vie des fois tu sais
jamais si tu as pris le site a fait le
bon choix ou pas après coup là on se
rend compte que ben ouais c'est lé
moment où il y avait des choix
questionnable et savent eux pouvaient
être les bons et les mauvais ben
rend compte que ceux qui ont fait
d'autres choix ont mieux réussi mais
après on a vu des peaux qui a qui a joué
serrure absolue et qui risquent plus
jamais rien et il a gagné les candidats
donc c'est toujours dur à dire
mais c'est vrai qu'on ne sache chikhi
riant
la jouer un peu plus c'était peut-être
pas si risqué que ça après on n'est pas
dans sa tête peut-être qu'il est malade
moi ça ça arrive que tu parles avec des
joueurs en off que soit maxime que ce
soit gris tchouk et quand tu leur
demandes tiens pourquoi tu as fait si
pourquoi tu as fait ce choix ils disent
ah ouais mais ce jour là j'avais mal à
la gorge avait des brûlures d'estomac
j'avais de la fièvre je sais pas il ya
aussi ce genre de choses qu'on sait pas
forcément de l'extérieur ça ça arrive ça
parle à un joueur après
et et le joueur en fait ils te dirais
mais là ce jour là j'avais une
intoxication alimentaire j'avais la
chiasse
je venais de prendre deux spectacles non
mais tu as ça arrive et je pouvais pas
jouer quoi juste
ça arrive aussi un je sais pas en fait
on peut pas savoir
tu peux pas savoir exactement pourquoi
les décisions sont prises
parfois il ya des choses aussi du
domaine de l'extra-sportif 1
jaffe tourbe et 8 qui est pas la
première ligne
est ce que ça peut donner pression pour
maxime
est
ce que ça peut donner pression pour
maxime
intervalles très issus mais c'est pas
des excuses
c'est de l'analyse après coup les
excuses n'importe quoi en fait
les gens je pense que vous avez un côté
des fois vous êtes content que
que les gens raté du coup ça
[Musique]
ça vous remet un biais cognitifs
on vient et surtout je n'en sais la vie
généralement les gens sont quand même
heureux des camps les autres rats
atteints c'est quand même quelque chose
de bien connu
mais à mais c'est compliqué après
il ya des fois tu étais juste moins fort
au 6
mai
fabiano s'est peut-être trompé
c'est vrai que tour des huit tours des
6es g6 truc la turbine est ça faisait
nul instantanée et fabick finalement
fait une erreur
à
voir peut-être fuite 17 est ce que ça
peut encore donner quelque chose
il ya peut-être quelque chose cette qui
s'est gouré fabi
ça doit draw encore
mais il s'est peut-être planté
d'ailleurs maxime surpris aussi de la
décision de fabié
et c'est drôle quand même
mais sa rage ou encore un peu
il peut encore y avoir erreur
fabiano qui s'est vraiment trompé là il
le sait j'ai parce qu'il a raté mais
tour des huit c'était vraiment très
simple pour des huit c'était instantanée
tour des huit tours des six buts lors
des 6 g sisteron des cinq
s'était fait incroyable au moment le
plus le coup le plus facile ils se
trompent fabiano
la concentration qui a lâché
donc ça à faire froid f8
il ya tour 17 aussi
qui on va voir
bon ça doit être nul
mais c'est peut-être pas si simple
c'est peu 6 1 17
concentré parce que s'il avait fait tour
des huit en fait c'est il y avait plus
rien à calculer s'était terminée terminé
sa cygnet déjà nul en fait
ce que le problème pour lui en fait si
froid aux sept ya des huit échecs roi
prend et on prend g7 ça c'est gagnant
est ce que tous ces huit trois f 7 17
non ça c'est tout reprend 17 c'est qu'on
ait cette île va faire h 5
h 4 il va faire g6 g3
il va faire droit aux sept des huit il
va faire froid prend tout rejet c'est 3
8 tours prend roi f7 tourage six tours
des 5 et ça malheureusement c'est nul
aussi
mais si c'était avec le purger six nuls
instantané
à la tension y est roi g7 qui enferme la
tour
c'est nul quand même
ça a l'air d'être nul quand même
fabiano qui était pas loin d'eux quand
même se met en plus grosse difficulté
après ça il avait vu mais juste il a pas
ici comment dire en fait je pense qu'il
s'est passé
c'est que comme il a beaucoup souffert
entre guillemets pour pour s'en sortir
fabiano il a vu que tout rebelle 8
rentrer dans un truc nul et il n'est pas
allé voir si tour des huit tours des six
était plus simple
et du coup c'est pour ça qu'il a fait
tomber 8 qui fait ça passe pas mais bon
ça il avait vu mais ça aurait pu être
plus chiant ça aurait pu être plus
chiant
encore le vertige de trop de succès vrai
c'est ça le vertige de trop de succès
c'est un truc qui est bien documentée
dans l'est dans la littérature
échiquéenne russe souvent on fait on
fait des erreurs quand
qu'on pense qu'on sentait complètement
sorties etc on a fait un gros effort en
un relâchement et on nous on arrête de
chercher la ligne 1 et on cherche on
commence à jouer une ligne qui nous
paraît correct
et du coup en fait tu te relâches tu
vois un truc qui passe et tu le joues au
lieu de continuer à mettre la pression à
100%
mais là il se trouve que ça passe parce
que parce que c'est du top niveau
et maxime il ya cru un maxima il a
compris maintenant il a compris ce qu'on
a vu avec la turbine est
mai mais il y as cru clairement
un
peu commenté sur la chanson après avoir
gagné 1,7 oui surtout si le tie-break
était serré
une ligne 17
ème et 17 tu vas pas faire recette de
cette recette des huit saga une salle
pour les blancs ça ça doit gagner
parce que le roi est coupée et on va
pouvoir monter le nôtre pour attaquer
les pions
c'est dommage j'aurais eu un c'est
dommage qu'ils aient pas eu en quelque
chose de plus compliqué un plus gros
piège c'est plutôt pour les blancs ça
oui mais va pas faire en fait des cinq
îles 17 il va pas faire
on va laisser le jouet le 40e ici on va
aller voir ali reza après
il faut pas faire
17 c'est pas un mauvais coup juste ça
suffit pas
juste ça ne suffit pas assez
c'est plus ça le problème
c'est 3 8 to run en tournée c'est 3,8
j'attends projet cette
année tour 17 à tour est bloqué en fait
et tu vas te faire f 5 et va faire chez
pas h4 qui va te faire g6 je vais faire
g3 et maintenant il va te faire roi 8
dont j'essaie tour des six
tours g63 f7 en fait il va tout le temps
à réussir à retourner dans cette finale
il ya un peu de volumes évoluent mérite
est là pour fabiano
un peu de volumes évoluent méritait
les as du coup ça se passe comment
on va mettre l'échiquier en grand
un peu de chance m a été fait avant et
ça est un peu de un poil de réussite
mais c'est normal qu'il ait en fait
mal qu'il est
détruis saatchi à rien
ouais
mais c'est un co peut pas remonter mais
c'est une bonne nouvelle
qui sait ça part de là
ça part de là
on est clairement shyqeri c'était un peu
le péno de cette fin de tournoi en haut
du tableau
cheyrou cas une belle position il ya
vraiment les cavaliers là qui ont
commencé à se masser sur le roc adverse
il a joué deux des quatre ici
non faussée 7
rendu fou qui va être rien sur des cats
et qui va taper
ses pinceaux c'est nul
c'est p nk hausse et a gagné
beaucoup trop nuls et yugo part in
a commencé à mal se passer pour vite
yougov ce histoire
dans 17 jours
elle
l'a fait j'ai cinq temporisateurs prend
des six
c'est drôle ça il le sait
ils les connaissent par coeur ces
finales
ils les connaissent par coeur
c'est chelou
non
pas le moins du monde malheureusement
le roi est coupée ouais mais il veut
juste récupérer pions en fait si tu
donnes le pion âge c'est pas grave
puisque les options restent ensemble
après moi je n'aurais pas fait mais
j'aurais fait h5 plus tôt mais ça va
encore ça
était l'objet d'un espion si si si si tu
finissais par le perdre
à voir si ali reza réussi à faire le taf
bon après
s'il ya quelqu'un qui perd là games et
caruana contre mayer il y avait bien un
pour cent de chance de gagner il a fini
par gagner là c'est pareil maxi 1000 à
1% de chance de gagner il va il va
tenter qui sait peut-être que ça sourire
maxime pas remonter son ras exception
est ça va s'échanger on verra on verra
un peu plus tard la partie de maxime
donc le
cette
position est compliqué j'aime bien les
blancs visuellement il ya égalité
matérielle on voit que les pièces
blanches sont mieux placés sur
l'échiquier
globalement
donc j'ai pu on prend un pion prend il
va mettre le foin en d4 bon c'est sûr
que les blancs sont mieux
c'est plus que visuel maintenant est-ce
que ça suffit pour être gagnant pas ça
c'est une autre question
trop paraît
logique
pas fou prend un cheese donc certains
monde peut-être mais en fait le fou en
d4 tellement bien il défend b2 il bloque
le pion il tape f6 mans s'est joué
d'ailleurs
tu m'as gasquet prend ici c'est fou
prend m6 déjà maintenant
les pièces blanches sont trop belles
d'emprunts dont on va pouvoir faire
peut-être même cavale et prend qui a
essayé trois l'étape et là bas
et alireza s'y trompe pas il se lève il
est parti pour la gagner celle-là
ali reza est parti pour la gagner
après ça peut être la bonne nouvelle
pour maxime alireza va refaire nul
demain fabiano aussi et avec un peu de
bol u6 on départage
lunch
il revient sur deux
ça lewin est qualifié d'office d'en
faire encore faire nul demain
cinq roquettes
et là y'a un gain déjà d'après la
turbine cavaliers prendre tu comprends
fou pranger 6 tu menaces de prendre 5
qui prend des cas tu prends des quatre
îles pranger si suprend m6
salaires terminée ça a l'air de terminer
ici pour ali reza qui va être quasiment
lui qualifié
dans la fille rouge et en gagnant celle
là
bas ils vont se mettre tous les deux
très bien quand même avec fabiano au
dessus de la mêlée
j'ai signé chez max pas encore
à bas prix ce qu'elle est si ça aille
aussi plutôt tout reprend alors fou
prend
tout reprend veux faire tout reprend
cavaliers prend qui est des six qui a
valu huit ans mes cahiers h6 bouger si
c'est plus facile
ce qui est un monde où ali reza et
maxime s'affronter où ils sont affrontés
un tous les deux
et ça s'était soldée sur une nulle
demain il faudra encore faire le tafsir
ou orales et noir son adversaire sera
peut-être en mousseline avec les blancs
s'est pas encore fait et maxime
peut-être en must win avec les noirs
contre un gars qui doit aussi être
emmené au swing il peut encore se passer
des choses
cavalli g7 dit laura kg 7 c'est aussi
une option
tout qui marche j'ai l'impression
on a merdé partage quand même veine oui
mais ça peut changer
des partages ça peut changer un
c'est pas quelque chose qui reste
immuable puisque les adversaires contre
qui tu as joué rejoue donc s'il marche
bien il marche moins bien
je peux remonter quoi
tata nano kalliste où l'eau du peloton
est emmené twin way quasiment tout le
monde sauf ali reza et fabiano
qui me vont vouloir faire d'eurofins
surtout firoud
ça joue sajou
maxwell avait l'air d'être nul sans trop
réfléchir effectivement
malheureusement
ok c'était
faire fou pranger ici c'est fou prend
1,5 mais en fait moi j'ai avalé à j 6
puis on prend fou prend et du compte ils
prennent des cas tu reprends et tu
bouffes f6
cruel
cruel mais c'est comme ça
on parle
pas de karwan à
ce que y en a qui est champion du monde
et l'autre pas
est ce qu'un inquiets champion du monde
ça peut oui
ça peut
objectivement ça craint pour mvr
s'ils gagnent d'heure marcy mais il aura
une toute petite chance oui une victoire
demain
et encore un tout petit monde louise
qualifier
un tout petit monde où heath qualifier
on ne sait jamais
en fait je regardais juste mais même
maintenant c'est ouf en fait à quel
point on a plus de monde que chess comme
en fête internationale je pense qu'en
réalité ils sont genre 1500 sur leur
live en vrai ils sont entre 1000 et 1500
c'est fou
c'est pas réussi à faire plus hype je
regarde un peu puisque là du coup quand
même une tension nerveuse qui retombe de
mon côté
mais c'est ouf en fait qu'il ait aussi
peu de monde qui regarde un joueur
américain qui peut se qualifier et tous
et que enfin potentiellement il doit
faire entre 10 et 20 fois plus quoi
s'écrie 4000 om en fait quand t'es
fait faut regarder les noms dans l'ailé
nombre de pseudo dans le chat quand tu
sais vraiment regardé
savoir combien ya vraiment deux mondes
les gens juste rien à [ __ ] c'est beau
bref c'est triste en bref
elle l'a fait cai m6 est joué
c'est triste
on prend 1,6 franges et 600 vrai ces
germes sont que c'est quasi abandon déjà
cotées côté côté owen
pour elle ça peut faire un mba lowell
demain ouais c'est ce qu'on va espérer
je sais pas si maxime nom maxime double
aurait pas les blancs mais ol il est
battable en vrai avec les noirs
ici aurait clairement numéro 1 français
après ce tournoi rabassi firouz
qualifiés aux candidats avec maxime n'y
est pas clairement firo est numéro 1
français et là y'a rien dit rien à dire
un
objectif je pense que ça les résas ou
maxime notre plus grande chanson tous
partis comptent magnus heures plus tôt
14 que 12
mais vu que ali riza 18 ans vu qu'il est
en train de se qualifier vu tout ce
qu'on voit j'ai envie de dire ali reza
forcément il est plus jeune et il semble
plus fort donc
voilà on ne peut pas dire l'inversé
après
maxime c'est peut-être moins son format
ces choses là on verra six qualifiés au
grand prix
marsh progression les réserves oui à
10,80 a encore beaucoup de marge de
progression
je pense qu'il est plus fort quand même
belle beille écoute le truc c'est qu'il
a plus des lots et qu'il en passe de se
qualifier quand maxime est en passe de
passes qualifiés donc à moins qu' un
tremblement terre demain un moment donné
c'est aussi la réalité est là il a
la une dizaine de points elo de plus
donc c'est anecdotique mais c'est quand
même ça il va déjà être qualifié au
candidat peut-être quand maxime le sera
pas dans ces cas là c'est dur de
considérer maxime comme plus fort
participent un graphe yahoo est cinglant
sinon ans maxime c'est un peu
dégueulasse à l'aps c'est la réussite
la chance sourit aux audacieux et la
foux pranger 3 seul coup vous dites ok
pour pions prend pions prend
vous prend et tour prends tu reprendras
b6 donc on peut pas faire le truc
linéaire joli piège
donc fou prend il doit voir commencer
par tout reprend
cavaliers prend et damages 5 avait
d'ailleurs des trucs comme ça
maxime et il réussit à avoir des petites
chances quand ça c'est le draw même
champions fc nul en vrai la position de
maxime même sens le pion au fc nul
il a l'air dégoûté maxima on va repasser
un peu sur
sur sa came il a dû y croire parce qu'il
avait la bonne prépa elle avait la bonne
position quelle partie incroyable de
deux caruana quand même
quelle défense de fabiano quand on y
pense
riskalis récemment sur nos deux joueurs
c'est un grand joueur famille
ça gagne pas non
ça ça ne gagne pas comme lui même si les
noirs n'avaient pas le pion au fc à
gagnerait pas
c'est comme ça
ça c'est les positions qu'ils gagnent
pas
enfin j'ai fait la guerre contre les
plots les plots qui n'arrivent pas à
wind bas après force aussi contre les
plots fabiano
- est-ce que je tiendrai a condé oui ça
je tiens c'est
pas très dur ça
rit tu te concentres arrivants
il meurt avec m eur qui a battu alex
nko'o et qui remonte un broyat bhl jeune
allemand
ça c'est les bonnes
c'est plus trop ce qu'on cherche à
suivre
sur jowell
l avis de l oms huard y trouve le four
en g3
complexe
je vous fais
ça joue mais bon y'a plus rien à faire
il va jouer par par inertie quoi
seulement pris fit 2022 avec deux places
or c'est déjà qualifié suffirait pour
une chanson de maxime se qualifier pour
les candidats c'est dur à dire il faudra
voir vraiment qui est les groupes les
machins mais ce sera un meilleur chaude
que ici clairement ça dépend si sogui
machin et joue
ça dépend de qui va cias auguri
rapporte etc ça va être dur mais là il a
de bonnes chances maxime ce que c'est un
format qui lui convient après si c'est
les mêmes joueurs qui s'ils - ali reza
et fabiano c'est 50%
faction du lot non pas cette fois ci
les rezaï gagnant way va pouvoir
récupérer le matos
ce que tu anticipes le derby bacrot
mvele au grand prix 1 1 ce serait dur a
well on paie alès well as well as à mon
avis c'est une question de temps qu'ils
abandonnent
en tout cas jolie performance de
d'alireza
jolie perf d'ali reza qui n'étaient pas
assurés
de se qualifier et qui avait besoin de
gagner qui avait la pression sur lui
après la défaite d'hier il a bien réussi
à rebondir
il a vraiment énormément progressé comme
ali reza sur toutes ces choses
il faudra il faudra aller chercher là
nul demain pour assurer la qualif
il ya trop de pression
sur écrasé une série de matches à 28
aces qui va tenir
c'est un peu ça le défaut de cette
qualif aux candidats au final au final
ça pue c'était comme un concours de qui
va le mieux les 2008 les 2650 plutôt de
savoir qui joue bien contre les joueurs
forts
mais ça fait aussi partie des choses
qu'il faut savoir faire
en live à prendre g3 prendre g6 prend
2,6 ça va encore jouer sont tellement
gagnant
mais peut-être qu'il n'a pas mieux que
ça
sera complète
nettement différent
vallier prend malheureusement
finalement car celui qui a le mieux joué
contre l'étape joueurs
comme quoi ceux qui ont battu les vans
et m'a tiré sur l'ambulance balle est
bonne il était complètement hors forme
maintenant ce tournoi
et maxime on va peut-être suivre
veut pas signer maxime il a l'air
dégoûté la
maxima vraiment leur dégoût il y as cru
hein c'est sûr
maxime ya cru ouais c'est la désillusion
pour
le numéro 2 français
a il est dégoûté je pense qu'avec le
tour prochain qu'il avait eu
il avait de bonnes chances ouais on voit
qu'il est dégoûté là ça se voit
ils ont discuté de ce qu'il a raté à mon
avis au monde une âme 3,5
ouais
difficile à encaisser
vraiment déçu vraiment déçu
on restait cette prise en main 5
gaffe de fierro
soissons va changer de bandits crois pas
trop je pense je me fais troll
pas du tout une gaffe f3
c'est hyper fort en fait il veut jouer
prise f6 avec la dame il ya une minute
dix
une nouvelle info chat
qui se présentent jamais froid au
contraire est très fort
après si on arrêtait de tout le temps
montré des ordis et complexes la
dernière je crois c'est vraiment fort sa
menace d'un problème si sa menace
d'armes pranger 3 et à vrai dire ah
ouais ok la turbine te donne seul coup
mais ouais c'est sûr qu'il a raté firoud
ces dames c6 le seul coup c'est hyper
dur à voir parce que c'est un match du
couloir qui est tellement pas habituel
c'est trouvable après dans le sens où
c'est absolument le seul coup mais je
pense qu'il va faire flasher 4.6
je pense que ça va rentrer là dedans
ah ouais dams et 6 avec avec quelques
secondes à la pendule s'est tendu on va
voir ce qu'il a joué
il a trouvé magnifique c'est est
trouvable dans le seul sens où c'est le
seul coup en fait mais c'est très bien
joué de la part de noël au pied du mur
avec quelques secondes avec quatre
secondes à la pendule il a joué
quelle défense
howell qui peut redonner des chances à
maxime d'ailleurs assis ça fait drôle
dans celle là évidemment on va pas être
on veut une victoire d'ali reza mais ça
peut donner à maxime noir demain contre
ol
il sera en mode swing avec les blancs et
ça peut relancer maxime dans la
compétition or là c'est un peu complexe
est ce qu'on préfère
et ce con
victoire d'ali reza pour calife ali reza
nul ici mettre tout le monde plus ou
moins encore en course
comme quoi ça peut vite tourner le sport
de haut niveau
mais si drogba voilà là ces
regroupements
c'est howell au noir demain il est
battable c'est n'importe quoi
c'est nimporte on va voir on va voir ce
qui se passe ici
ouais non mais laisse à ton tellement
vite d'un f3 un coût qui n'était pas du
tout obligatoire et alireza qui rate
dams et 6 quelle erreur quand même
d'alireza on disait qu'il était très
mature et qui réalisait une excellente
partie et là il fait vraiment une énorme
gaffe quand même à ce niveau là
il était il a été trop facile alireza il
était déjà il était déjà debout il
pensait que la partie était terminée
et la whey il est déjà il est en fait en
fait c'est vraiment une énorme gaffe
parce que dams et 6 d'accord il n'est
pas facile mais avec 20 minutes à la
pendule il a joué d'un beffroi en
seulement 2 minutes 20
c'est vrai pas simple en fait
le site eu des cas de la tour genre
bêtement un coup de tour maintenant il
ya fou hk tout faux 5 et le cavalier est
défendu par l'adam enfin deux variantes
donc en réalité ça donne poussée de
force et dames français deux dames
pranger trois dames g6
d'un projet si on prend g6 ou pro f 6
et ça c'est très proche de droit
et ça va or jouer mais un
mais c'est très proche de droit
ce thème ces six là qu'il allait
chercher
pour mais la position reste avantageuse
a quand même pour ali reza il va pas
perdre un
il va à voir
dams et 3 3 je pense le même problème
d'un printemps reprend fou aux cinq où
il ya même du retour un match mais je
veux dire en fait je fais france et roi
du kung fu ou cinq
noms mais il va trouver fous ces deux il
va quand même encore prêt c1 c2 dame
prend en fait c'est les noirs qui vont
devoir faire nul quand même ici
si c'est quand même les noirs qui doit
faire nul encore
mais ici quand même aller rezaï va
encore prêt sert
comment la finale ben ses pions de plus
pour les blancs et talent fou en d4 qui
va être bien placé donc
ouais faut encore la défendre avec les
noirs quand même pas fait pour les noirs
elle est nulle mais mais mais tu va la
jouer un petit peu avec les ventes us et
de créer un pion passer et tu veux un
peu la jouer mais normalement tu vas
rien obtenir le problème c'est que le
pion à quatre blocs à troyes b 2
normalement réussir à faire nul mais bon
tu vas un peu la jouer
là en revanche qu'il faut passer
complètement tilt parce que d'un f3 il a
vraiment raté le dame c6
est en réalité il a du bol d'avoir le
fou c'est de ali reza mesdames si
c'était dur à voir un handbike il s'est
trop relâché ça c'est encore une erreur
mentale plus que plus qu'une faute de
calcul
ouais en quelque sorte pas tout à fait
mais quand même un peu une similitude
erreur de jeunesse 20 simple peu comme
la faute de carre one a en réalité un
moment donné là le roi et fuite mais qui
n'en était pas vraiment une mais là le
drame f3c c'est vraiment une faute
étonnante après
sa vraie dans le tournoi faut que
j'aille voir le classement là parce que
je n'ai plus en tête du coup ça devient
n'importe quoi ce classement
ce classement devient n'importe quoi
parce que du coup ça donnerait caruana
cet arrêt mais en fait ce serait
n'importe quoi ça remettrait pas
forcément si bien maxime que ça mais
quand même un peu mieux on va durer tout
le monde à cette a6 amy aurait des
groupes à cette année maxime quoi le
secret beaucoup de monde à 7 quand même
le seul avantage c'est que nos
adversaires
pourraient être orwell
bon je sais pas en vrai vaut mieux qu
ali reza gagne quand même ça sur un
français
parce qu'en fait alireza il se retrouve
dans un ballottage un peu bizarre en cas
de nul non il vaut mieux qu ali reza
gagner en fait
je pensais qu ali reza pouvait peut-être
être quasi qualifant cadre au met mais
en fait c'est pas le cas faut vraiment
qu'ils gagnent
parce que derrière
ces gens sarksian ça finisse et comme
une bonne nouvelle
prête que d'aller voir un peu les autres
tables
prêtre rare aux usa ça peut être
important
et ça c'est drôle aussi donc ça c'est
des bonnes nouvelles en vrai il ya des
bonnes nouvelles la qui tombe pour les
deux français pour la peine
prête que anthony guiraud et du coup
shirov
en fait c'est au pari qui pourrait
prendre que pourrait prendre maxime
echirolles vite yugo venu là où il n'y a
que des bonnes news en fait
donc il ya
non shirov ce n'est pas celui-là merde
shirov junghee
et ça c'est chaud
il fit ugo paris voilà c'est ça
c'est quand même spécial
si maxime pouvait jouer au par ina
qui double noir un an mais maxime
aurécois recommande maintenant je sais
pas c'est bizarre là
ouais non c'est le
c'est très difficile qu'il ya beaucoup
de parties en cours et c'est difficile
de
faire des plans sur la comète mais
beaucoup de nuls il ya des gars bizarre
qui gagne c'est space
il
c'est entre les mains ouais mais c'est
aussi intéressant par rapport à fuir ou
déjà en fait fi rouge a peut-être que
deux nuls lui suffisent pas non plus
malgré son bon des partages et malgré le
fait qu'ils donnent pas de points à
l'adversaire
en fait nul aujourd'hui il met assez mal
ça annule aujourd'hui il alla les noirs
à la dernière ça le met dans une loterie
de folie en fait
de futura sur les sports maxime pas
vraiment parce que du coup ça mais
howell à cet ennemi et enfin ewell il a
6 ennemis aussi ça éloigne complètement
howell en fait
non en fait focalisa gagne parce que
sinon
sinon c'est le bordel c'est même pas sûr
qu'on en est un des deux candidats
mais la c même dame f3 c'est fou hein
précités dur à voir il a dû se dire que
ça ce n'est pas si simple à gagner il
doit avoir raison
c'est très chiant à jouer pour les noirs
parce que [ __ ] couleurs opposées
favorise la tacc
donc c'est quand même pas loin d'être
gagnant ça le fou en d4 va être
monstrueux le roi je devais être caché
on va attaquer le roi adverse
mais il va encore falloir travailler au
corps et il s'est dit oui bon je les
défonçant tactique d'un f3 fini la
partie sur le champ
il a complètement oublié dams et six en
fait
c'est c'est eh ouais c'est une énorme
erreur quand même alors c'est
à jouer comme s'ils se trouvaient avec
quatre secondes mais il avait vraiment
quatre secondes au moment d'appuyer
il a joué quoi
c'est quoi les coûts
il a joué pouces et 2
et contre gaffes
et contre gaffe ou 2,8
ok
quel jouet tempo
donc d'un problème 6 d'un problème si ce
fou prend un f6 et tour c'est 8 après
c'est peut-être trop quand même
vous c3 et ouais ok
ça reste chaud
ça reste très chaud
mais de façon ça aussi entre gros
avantage du fin c'est entre avantages
blanc et gains
garde les fous alors tu as les cheveux
fous de couleur opposée c'est exactement
ça le problème
mais ça peut encore passer pour ali reza
voit la façon d'un problème si c'est ce
qui va jouer c'est sûr
d'un problème si sa force d'âme pro f 6
parce que sa menace maths en premier sur
flu progressiste j'imagine qu'ils adam
français de 1
dames g3 d'amour et 6
bref c'est juste le coup logique dame
prend vous prend
mais j'imagine il va faire pour ces huit
pour vaud le clouage vous ces trois
s'efforcer food et 6 pour je vous prends
à 3
royaux reffouh prend bien évidemment
bon ça donne l'impression que ça va le
faire quand même mais quelle partie un
rebondissement
est fou h7 le prime jeunesse juste
cavaliers prendre tout reprendre et tout
remettre à chaque fois
je pense qu'il va faire dans le principe
d'un problème si c'est quasiment sûr on
va remettre la grande gamme
voilà s'est joué
d'un prendre un prof ou prends
ça redonne le temps de réfléchir il
récupère 30 secondes et ours et 8
il n'a pas
david howell de finale
et je sens du quintette a le droit un
coup je sais pas combien à droite où
exactement sans écrire l'endroit était
censé écrire vraiment à préchac chaque
truc
censées noter du coup est joué après
je sais pas si c'est un coût complet ou
si c'est un demi coup
sur coup ces trois des quatre shows m et
des quatre fous des deux
non pas quand il a 30 secondes de
rajouts
j'espérais que des quatre passes en fait
bref khachatur d1
du coup il va sûrement faire food et 6
par tiens c'est incroyable
la partie assez incroyable
et il semble
il semble que ça va passer pour ali reza
dans une partie acharnée et heureusement
parce qu'un jeu dit elle à l'annuler en
vrai
il y avait beaucoup plus de risques que
les héros france aux candidats que un
sur deux
sûrement y avoir fou des deux
qui va taper en plus en âge 6
prend des quatre il doit y avoir foule f
5 1 donc ouais fou des deux joué par ali
reza
howell qui sud rail
pourra s'en vouloir aux ailes
et de menaces vous prend 1,4 fo prend un
capteur français
je pense qu'il va j'essaie de foot est
roi et la finale doit être gagnante pour
les blancs à vrai dire
le pion des cats paraît faible quand
même
ça paraît bhl le pion des 4 paraît
faible
il a fait roi g7 c'était sûr
à rentrer dans cette finale
bientôt ajoutant il reste quatre coups
mais finale qui doit gagner pour les
blancs
parce que il va pouvoir sûrement échangé
à b contre à se faire un pion passé ici
est un pion passé de ce côté là ça doit
suffire pour gagner
il aurait pu avoir plus ou moins la même
avec votre couleur opposée qui était
drouot elle il s'est trompé
tu dois pouvoir faire des pions passé
des deux côtés et gagner
à voir ali reza qui réfléchit
on n'est jamais sûr à 100% de les gagner
ces finales là
je sais qu'à grande chance mais
puis en d4 peut être faible 6 mai bref
toujours faire gaffe sait jamais je
prends pas un joueur de forteresse une
merde
may ou peut-être en train de retourner
chez rock you you for à faire attention
et
non que les plus isolés est vrai mais
bon
doit gagner
c'est pas toi nyoni bas que j'apprendrai
qu'il ya des finales parfois un peu
bizarre la pression étant à son comble
l'enjeu de la victoire étant une place
au candidat quasiment on peut comprendre
que tu sois un peu stressé tomber dans
un cas spécial qui gagne pas
c'est vrai
ce jeu est tellement complexe
mais la fête des droits
hors france et un tempo france est un
il reste trois courts
et absent qui va essayer de faire
acheter à 5 pour bloquer les pions
à voir si à
si la gagne ou pas je pense qu'elle est
gagnant déjà aucun risque de défaite ça
c'est impossible
la seule question c'est ce qu'elle gagne
ou pas
sale et unique question
à
vrai nom j'ai pas le plan de gains en
fait avec les blancs mais
globalement a
envie de ramener ton roi m le font ses
deux fers b3 commença à pousser là bas
et gagner
c'est de donner envie en fait
bon
d'être des contres comme ça
auxquels il faut faire attention qui
serait gagnant si le roi était bien
placé mais faut faire gaffe que le roi
noir montrent pas trop tu as peut-être
envie de préparer ramener tranquillement
ton roi puis faire pousser 2 et essayer
de le faire tranquillement
on part in qui explose it you go away et
ue
et yuki en train de se la gagner contre
chir of
you en train de remonter
youtube farine ou par in en train de
faire le taf in avec des fonds ses
envies de sault paris n'y a pas
longtemps
avait juste défoncé
à la bonne partie
la fesci qui a tout fait pour fixer
mais à vrai dire
le pion h qui est vraiment mal placé 1
lui aussi est isolé
j'habite je pars inaba sur la multitude
de partis qu'on a fait oui
mais mais mais il me défonce globalement
il est assez incroyable ils calculent
vraiment vite
il est vraiment incroyable
gagner ça
trop de faiblesses chez noir
toi tu peux de consolider et normalement
peut-être un fou en d1 va faire mal
ton vous attaquera là et là à la fois tu
frappes étroite enverra t pionsat doit
gagner
je vois pas gagnerez pas en fait
c'est surtout ça
ce que j'avais raison en bullet je pense
pas
avoir battu fédérer en bullet
il a fait j'ai 3
à vrai dire ça a l'air cool ouais ça a
l'air cool pour ali reza c'est son 40e
coup
à la finale donne vraiment envie
par une nouvelle demain ça peut winneway
bien sûr après oui n'est peut-être plus
suffisant
ça que je veux dire
en fait c'est ça le problème
c'est que c'est pas dit que nul passe
et c'est le problème
si c'était sûr connu le passé on serait
tranquille un
que vie passé on serait tranquille mais
c'est pas sûr qu'ils histoire passe par
l'ons excusez moi je suis déconcentré
tchèque un truc
pour moi ça a été fini
du coup il ya le petit moment
comme d'habitude
de battement
le classique
thor fils des fêtes de fabio je sais par
rapport à calculer il peut y avoir les
départager peur beaucoup de choses
on va avoir un an cette finale qui se
lancent évidemment ça va prendre du
temps puisqu'elle rajout les 50 minutes
mais ali reza est bien parti
n'a pas l'air content de son coup et je
pense que son problème c'est qu'il va y
voit que le fou va venir ici en d1 et
qui a b 3 qui arrive
donc
ça doit pas le faire en fait un
ça doit pas et
ça ne doit c'est
j'ai une junior tu es vraiment
impeccable et prouesses coin du stream
sur czech comme suit moder plus d'un
second tour ou non pas du tout oh que
non oh que non
oh que non les délires ne sont pas
modérés je te rassure
c'est juste que c'est différent de
de castin un tournoi
où deux ou de jouer ou quoi
je pensais que c'est sûr si marine
embrassait c'est la même chose c'est
juste le format des tournois des
compétitions qui fait kiffer ça hein
ça dépend de ce qu'on fait mais
voilà on a plus qu'à attendre en vrai
c'est le moment vraiment inintéressant
de la partie à chaque fois parce que ça
temporise vraiment très longtemps
je fais le résumé ce soir tout seul d'un
parti de maxime
autant dire que ça va tuer
j'ai un emploi du temps un peu un peu un
peu complexe on va dire ça comme ça
j'atteste
est un peu complexe aujourd'hui ça s'est
un peu calmé
tu as été un petit peu complexe
peut pousser quand je suis allé voir
ouais ça paraissait intéressant pour you
en fait je vous vois pas dans quel monde
c'est pas juste complètement gagnant
pour les blancs
japan on cale on ne sait pas gagner en
fait je n'arrive pas à comprendre le la
difficulté
non
non non ce soir sera ma tout ce qu'on
sait tous seuls et crée deux journées
longues comme ça c'est pas évident on
sera une analyse express ans j'annonce
by a de la difficulté à peut-être pas
difficulté vrai
salaire juste complètement gagnant tu
vas pouvoir échanger b contre a envoyé
le pion et site aptitude à échanger les
fous tu tapera le pion des cartes aura
le pion passer de l'autre côté fait vous
allez voir c'est c'est le scénario qui
va arriver mais ça paraît
indéfendable
caruana ya tellement bien joué
le niveau du candidat karama facile à
wayne on met caruana comme j'ai dit il
mérite il ya un indien là ce qu'il a
réalisé caruana c'est incroyable
j'avoue être candidat abbas et se
qualifier pour le tour des candidats en
fait être être candidat c'est se
qualifier pour le tour des candidats
gamer mvl ouais ce serait plutôt bien
aussi
maxime il peut sortir une win demain à
mon avis
mon avis ça peut gagner
l'assemblée sans qualifier s'ils gagnent
joli nom pour revenir demain
je veux qu il a joué f5
à une nulle doit suffire
trop bon départager trop d'avancé
donc une nulle doit suffire pour ali
reza mais bon qui sait
on verra
peut se passer des choses encore dans ce
tournoi il peut se passer des choses
400 gagner je me posais la question
il faut être quatre trucs c'est à tout
et pions sur noir l'autre à les pions
sur blanc
bref 4 tata
abba il peut hein il est passé pas loin
de la correctionnelle cave ainsi le
dames c'est ici c'est gagnant pour les
noirs c'est pareil
mais de façon pour gagner des open comme
ça il faut bien jouer il faut aussi un
poil de réussite a dit reza à cette
réussite avec lui mais c'est de la
réussite provoquer un cap viser tout à
l'heure il a quand même il a quand même
bien poussé
plusieurs positions et la chance sourit
aux audacieux je me répète un petit peu
mais
mais il a il s'est décarcassée quand il
le fallait la faire aux deux plus
tranquille fois f4 il le fait quand
quand il veut une façon ça se voit qu'il
est gagnant il le sait est un
il est gagnant et il le sait
il la provoque chance est
arrivé il la mérite un
et il la mérite
sajoo 1 nathan
on me donne l'impression qu'elle lit
reza un plus et que maxime globalement
est c'est le cas c'est le cas
c'est le cas
il a plus poussée
et ça a marché après comme je le disais
un
aussi prendre l'exemple de
deux dépôts qui a arrêté complètement de
pouce et qui fait maintenant exactement
comme maxime on disait où il a pris en
maturité dans son jeu c'est très bien et
il a gagné les candidats donc c'est
toujours très facile de critiquer ou
dans ce sens et a posteriori
c'est toujours très facile
là ce moment du tournoi c'est aussi pas
mal je dois dire
on va dire que c'est réussi pas mal
driss il avait fait pareil
s'est mis à jouer comme ça une épaule il
s'est mis à faire que des droits
insipide avec les noirs et attend les
occasions il s'en fout
arch pour lui tant mieux 1
on aura
semaine prochaine vers le championnat
d'europe
par équipes avec l'équipe de france du
coup qui alignera
grosse timmins avec lvl
fil rouge à
etienne bacrot
jules moussard et maxime lagarde sans
emmenée par
seth mazet
jorisch king mais on sait pas assez maso
qui décide des échiquiers ça peut
parfois être malin de mettre des forts
un peu derrière fin on verra pour le
championnat d'europe par équipes là il
va faire froid les deux rois ces deux il
va essayer de faire b3 envoyé son pion
c'est complètement terminé derrière sa
joie assez vite à aujourd'hui
les raisins qui savent immédiatement là
il sait comment gagner
en dix-sept avec le fou
il veut faire froid ces deux bébés trois
rois célibattante est faux aussi
j'imagine
b5 four b3
roi des trois
brefs 6
il va falloir progresser à partir de là
peut-être fou ces quatre ans et quatre
français 4 dati va essayer d'avoir des
positions comme ça je sais pas on va
voir
ça doit être gagnant mais faut pas faux
pas gaffer pour pour ali reza
ça a l'air de gagner tranquille mais a
peut-être des pièges quand échanger fou
de cases blanches des contres avec un
roi qui monte qui sait
c'est
ils ont dans les rangs des adversaires
en tout cas être départagés à chase
réals
ça
salaire de gagner facile os à l'air
d'être assez facile effectivement
c'est de jouer ça a pas l'air très
compliqué ça je suis
entièrement d'accord
le rallye reza qui se barrent
immédiatement
ils se détendent ils vont se promener
seins
ils vont souffle aux terres
ça souffle at ça souffle at
c'est complètement perdu
je sais pas vraiment pourquoi ça joue en
fait il va pousser comme je disais il va
échanger ses options il ya le pion de
l'ale qui va partir et il a une auto
outils options plus et à qui on pas
s'éloigner il ya les faiblesses partout
pour les noirs
ça a l'air hyper simple a gagné
honnêtement ça a l'air très simple à
gagner
ça a l'air hyper simple à gagner
enfin l'auteur il ya des chances oui
c'est sûr qu'il eut la bourde mais là il
ya plumail moyens de faire une bourde
april a la baraka dans ce tournoi
quant à la barraca ça donne envie
d'essayer un petit peu quoi
bon
car elle dure jusqu'à un certain temps
et aux paris qui a gagné ray incroyable
un
passionné toujours des plots qui menace
un os part in c'est un excellent joueur
mais bon il n'était même pas qualifiée
au championnat de russie je crois
mais c'est juste que sur la masse de
joueurs entre guillemets en dessous
comme ils jouent entre eux y en a
forcément un qui arrive quoi
c'est l'armé des plots
qui est extrêmement dangereuse
elle favorisera remet des plots
1 ça implose seul ne peut rien faire
mais une armée y en a trop partout en
fait
espérer que si rafraîchissant à tenir
ce qu'on part insee gagnaire il a battu
il a battu vite yougov
j'en arrive et quand se passe
aujourd'hui pour mvl il a fait nul
maxime au classement elo il est pas mal
n'a pas vraiment perdu deux points il
sera bien pour les grands prix fidon
suivra toute façon les grands prix
finances en blanc
en a profité pour mettre un peu plus de
pub maintenant il sort de rattraper un
peu le coup
y'a des fous ici c'est façon si sûr qui
va
d'achat d'or
j'espère briller renforçant jeu
d'assurer l'annulerait je pense que
firent où il a fait exprès et l'a même
fait exprès de faire une gaffe
aujourd'hui contre de faire le dernier
froid contre ol
pour donner espoir à redonner espoir à
maxime et
faire et faire semblant qui laissa un
demi point tout en maîtrise pas ce
qu'ils savaient qu elle avait pas trouvé
je pense
je fais trois mais le roi va pouvoir
monter
presque vraiment été meilleur que les
plots abbaoui
largement
maxime il a bien joué sur le tournoi
maxime irréaliste quand même un bon
tournoi a juste un moment donné
c'est ça le con tre shirov en fait il
fallait tout gagné avec les blancs tout
le temps
et il a raté contre shirov un plot il
fallait faire 100% avec les blancs
contre les plots et à
et il en a raté une
celle qu'il fallait pas rater
c'est ça le problème c'est tout le
tournoi en soit
il a raté une partie une demie parti
même
c'est comme ça
favori voilà sur ce tournoi en vrai
si tu prends pas mvl et firent ou chat
envie que ce soit car wadin qui se
qualifie
quand même
soyons soyons honnêtes 1 c'est sur le
jeu
les trois qui mérite c'est fuir ou mvl
et caruana c'est les 3 tu veux voir là
bas
ouais t'as les
3c les trois joueurs que tu as envie de
voir quoi
c'est ce qu'on disait au début du
tournoi a vraiment dit que c'étaient les
trois plus forts aronian on savait pas
trop
maintenant ça alireza de l'ouest alireza
jouer je sais pas ça réfléchit à ses
jours le moment où ça met des plombes
gens qui va faire genre fou b5
poupée trois rois des trois-rois bout
ces cas de foot et un roi des deux
bref trois fous p5 quelque chose comme
ça
et tu vas réussir à bouffer là et il va
tenter un genre de contre jeu ici
quelque sorte c'est ça l'idée des noirs
c'est tenter un truc comme ça
mais bon ça doit être complètement foutu
pour les noirs mais il doit espérer
quelque part avoir une drôle
c'est pas possible ce truc de savoir
pourquoi ya pas un nombre de parties
père c'est un copy paste ah c'est pas
possible
tout le monde pose exactement la même
question et on a 50 100 200 par jour
c'est obligatoirement un copie pasta
je pense obligatoirement copy paste à où
commencer je vois pas d'autre solution
ceci n'est pas le chat
la question revient tellement souvent
que je me dis ça doit être un copie
pasta
et un coup moi aussi je m'endors fait ça
paraît tellement gagnant que
du mais c'est quoi
sinon pour le monde avec la rente que je
viens de montrer
qui semble gagner mais ça doit pas être
la seule à
ça ne doit pas être la seule
gilleron en d3
terrible
deux parties mais on a fait le tour plus
qu'à faire les coûts là enfin je me
répète pour la 100e fois mais je vois
aucun scénario dangereux je suis en
attente comme vous en fait ça se voit
qu'ils ali reza comprends pas trop non
plus ça c'est typique le genre de partie
si tu rajoutes un quart d'heure chacun
là à l'affût de la partie finie en 15 20
minutes max est là elle va finir on est
déjà à 38 de jeu et à mon avis on a
encore une demi heure quoique même pas
sûr
c'est vraiment la cadence qui fait que
ça avec sajoo
eshiro à la raison de prendre son temps
il a déjà fait une connerie tout à
l'heure avec l'edf 3
pas très bien inspiré de faire la même
complexe
yang
mission pour gagner ne serait pas idéal
les échecs sur notre recherche de
perfection c'est plus vraiment le cas
sky bobby
manque 30 30 ans l'a pas trente ans de
retard frérot
charge de perfection
c'est puis les parties d'échecs
construit ensemble
fait tourner des turbines 1
c'était le cas encore dans les années
jusqu aux années 70 80
oui quelques années de retard
ouais mon plat
le pion plus va parler un
le pion de plus va parler
donc alireza il faudra quand même là nul
1 demain si père il y sera pas au
candidat demain sera une journée
vraiment décisive il aura les noirs donc
nul avec les noirs même contre un joueur
à 26,50 c'est pas sur ce que son
adversaire lui sera vraiment
en must en me swing d'ô qui tentera tout
cas ce rallye je joue et je n'étais pas
le tableau peut-être 90 mais c'est déjà
30 ans 1 90
tu foutu
il fallait finir les mv le gagnes tu
seras devants à 7 et nuit on sait pas
probablement fabi mais c'est pas 100%
et partage
et d'une ronde à l'autre donc
qui l'a fait roi et fils
peut-être sur fous ces quatre vous prend
droit prend airois f5 ouais ça la
turbine a dit que ça va pas être gagnant
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut lui faire
confiance
et il veut faire ça qui peu embrouillé
et
ça ça pourrait être une erreur
donc il faut un peu vigilants
d'être soudés 7
d un fou des deux fous b3
mais il faut trouver comment progresser
à vrai dire
peut-être foulée 4 après tout ces cinq
faut prendre des cathos qui aimerait ça
ça gagne c'est le plus simple vous 17
refoulé deux fauves et quatre pouces et
5 fu prend des quatre
et une fois que tu as fait fou prend des
cats abandon
et là je vois vraiment pas comment
comment défendre dans ces cas là
fu 17 pour bloquer l'avancée du roi et
food et de fougue et quatre pouces et 5
c'est imparable
absolument rien à faire pour les noirs
il ya des quatre qui tombe ça fera deux
pions de plus
après on aura plus qu'à mettre le fou en
c2 avant c'est vrai c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment vraiment facile à
gagner
et ça c'est le plus simple
vos six patients pour le blanc à
monsieur affaires points 4
tu vas pas gagné d mais du coup tu
gagnes ce pion
state qui donne la meilleure chance mais
elle j'y crois pas du tout
j'y crois seule seconde à ce coup
je n'y crois pas une seule seconde
ça va gagner la sarre a gagné très
tranquillement
il traîne
qui traîne et rennes
s'est bien remis de sa partie d'après il
a aussi eu du bol un peu et les raisins
parce qu'il avait il a bien joué et puis
l'a quand même fait une grosse gaffe de
toute façon faut toujours de la réussite
en vrai
alors là c'est sûr que c'est mort
c'est pas dur il en est beaucoup et well
as well as réussite il en a eu beaucoup
je pense qu'il va abandonner sa se voit
en plus son langage corporel etoudi qui
sait aussi que ces excès perdu fait là
tout le monde sait que c'est gagné pour
les blancs il ya même plus de pièges et
a plus rien là c'est vraiment
pas ya même plus un allié en fait c'est
juste une accueillir le pion
accueil réservé à revenir pas de
frôlements il attend la bande ont fait
tout le monde attend l'abandon ici
ce avant une tête de mule sowell
après on n'a jamais gagné une partie en
abandonnant c'est pas faux non plus
la désillusion de perdre
ce moment
je joue mais la salle assez là c'est
vraiment désespéré un
là en fait le truc c'est que
trouver un piège semble difficile en
fait le plan est vraiment simple
et ne doit pas être unique d'ailleurs
genre c'est une des manières de gagner
c'est la plus simple que j'ai trouvée
mais peut-être que si on se décarcasse
ne trouve une deuxième une troisième
quatrième
ça paraît vraiment logique en fait ça
gagne en ligne
louis david ça fait longtemps qu'ils
tombent sur plus fort que lui mais qui
s'en sort
voici les trouver sur encore plus fort
qui peut répliquer ton plan à mon plan
il est semble assez de décaler le fou et
d'aller gratter le pion
c'est simple 1
c'est trouver des pillages david
c'est dommage que ma si aujourd'hui elle
pas été appariés contre elle mais
c'était pas possible en fait ce qui
n'est pas encore joué caruana
il était obligé de prendre caruana ou
blanc
bref quatre mieux non tu peux aussi
jouer avec fief quatre fous bouche ou
des six faisait 5 1 ça doit gagner faire
comme judy à plein de manières
il n'y a pas une manière de gagner
elle a fait foot et 2
après il trouve qu'on a souvent la même
manière de gagner parce que c'est la
plus évidente
faire la manière la plus facile
vous devez vraiment logique et ne les
noirs n'ont pas de coût dont pas d'idées
le roi est bloquée enfin 3 m6 ou b4
tout est bloqué
il n'y a rien à dire
fines gueules d'enterrement ouais ouais
là
mais je comprends il était perdant il
n'est pas passé loin
cette fois ci quand tu perds des quatre
c'est vraiment 100% foot u
terrible pour david
il faudra le travail demain pour ali
reza
pour s'assurer d'avoir au moins un
français aux candidats ce qui sera
cool
maxime faudra tout donner
pour tenter d'y aller aussi et il y aura
encore la séance de rattrapage avec les
grands mots les grands prix fidh
les grands prix fier de nom ce sera
ouais c'est dur mais y aura moins de
chance qu ici après le problème c'est
que la probabilité qu'il y ait des
joueurs plus forts est aussi grande d'un
autre côté il y aura pas caruana et
y'aura pas fuir ou déjà
peut-être
il y aura des plots entre la 3e et la 6e
et la 8e place qui se qualifieront
sont pas forcément que des mauvaises
choses
je sais pas si les dates sont arrêtées à
des grands prix filmer ce sera février
mars avril
chez sky part du bliss lundi à riga ya
un enjeu aucun
au moins ces pratiques
pratique
désolé les amis en life
la meubler là j'ai du mal à me blesse
c'est quand même le 10e jour de
commentaire
des moments on a envie de
de chill à
samedi soir à la tranquille j'ai encore
et encore deux heures de prépa pour la
vidéo derrière et après ça va chill
à qui paul gellé bon qu'à quitter dès
que la partie se termine je vais manger
un cas qui
a déménagé norge des ménages mardi et
s'arrête la galère parce qu'en fait j'ai
rien pu préparer jusqu'à demain je peux
rien préparé parce que je suis obligée
de laisser mon studio et je travaille
beaucoup trop j'ai vraiment pas le temps
et du coup je dois préparer tout mon
déménagement lundi je sais pas comment
je vais faire
je sais pas comment je vais faire
sais pas comment je vais faire j'ai
tellement peu de temps libre
mais bon je m'en sortir un
cd ménagement en inclinant je suis pas
enfin c'est ma femme qui s'occupe un peu
un peu de pas mal de choses mais je suis
un peu inquiet pour le set up le studio
et où
une pause impressions après de l'argent
peut-être à oui mais vendredi il ya le
championnat d'europe par équipes qui
recommence
donc
non en fait juste pas de temps en fait
une personne qui n'a pas de temps
terrible
après je m'en plains pas je suis content
de pas avoir de temps
quelque chose qui m'embête de pas avoir
de temps au contraire au moins les
journées sont bien bien
bien remplie c'est cool j'aime pas trop
avoir de temps libre à rien faire en
fait
l'impression de perdre mon temps quand
ça arrive
lors des scream ah bah non il va ya voir
mardi orale title avec fable du coup je
pourrais tester internet et le nouveau
set up ça me permettra de
tester
de voir que tout marche bien donc ça ce
sera cool mercredi on fera peut-être
l'aréna kings jeudi on fera peut-être dû
du gaming on verra
ce sont pas contraires
lannion ferai un petit
un petit stream cours avec un petit
débrief du tournoi à ce que vous avez
pensé des commentaires etc
selena qui arrive à fond pour la vie
pratique ah ouais bah sinon là j'ai
vraiment pas de temps
voilà quand c'est des tournois comme sa
fougue faut que tu dises que je passe
rien en gros 10 heures par jour sur le
truc tu vois il ya eu il va y avoir aux
rondes ça à faire sans 10h en 12 jours
enfin au bout d'un moment je suis même
juste fatigué c'est dur
d'avoir le temps pour faire des choses
geagea internet gérer l essence et
marché
wen ont dit non lundi je vais faire quoi
lundi je vais les mettre un trou dans le
mur pour pour faire passer un fil
pour internet
ou sur autre chose quand tu auras 40 en
plus
pourquoi n'y a ni bas
tu trouves que sur un vieux croûton
ouais
on se lasse
je sais pas ce fait déjà dix ans que je
fais ça je veux pas l'impression de me
lasser
c'est en
moi je pense vous inventez des life avec
le temps en fait
je pense que les gens qui n'ont pas
assez de temps ce sont les gens qui sont
mal organisées
hors problèmes de santé bien évidemment
aux problèmes de santé mais a sinon je
pense que les gens qui n'ont pas le
temps sur les gens juste mal organisées
ou qui dorment trop parce qu'ils foutent
était organisée et que tu perds pas tant
à rien faire tu peux faire tellement de
choses dans une journée
fouteret
j'ai l'impression que
le temps ça s'organise sur tout et qu'on
a toujours le temps de faire les choses
qu'on veut faire et puis si on n'a pas
le temps de faire des choses qu'on veut
faire on peut les délégués et puis et
puis on peut toujours se débrouiller
après la santé oui ça c'est un autre
problème
voilà vides abandonnées ray
c'est épuisant avoir des journées sous
productives tous les jours
ouais non j'suis pas d'accord en fait mr
pour les enfants je sais pas trop mais
je vous fais je connais personnellement
des gens qui ont des enfants et qui sont
full occuper un fond plein plein de
choses sont pas spécialement
qui n'arrête pas de travailler ou quoi
parce qu'ils ont des enfants mais après
une question de gestion 1
de priorisation et ses
rites yuko avec les to kill a quatre
enfants dont quatre enfants avec katia
tu en as un temps d'1 qui a fait les
candidats et l'autre qui est vice
championne du monde quoi enfin
pas l'impression que qu'ils aient dû
arrêter les échecs à cause de ça en fait
mais après comme visé le mas plus le
côté santé où je suis d'accord après
peut-être que tu peu moins moins
enchaîné les journées longues
voyez par an dans les sens mais je crois
qu elle
fait le truc c'est que là il veut fouet
f4 food et six pouces et 5 et le juge
chasser le four à vrai dire juste pour
expliquer surtout pkt peut-être f4 alors
qui doit être complètement gagnant quand
même pour les blancs mais bon
c'est relou et peut-être fou f4f 6 food
et 6 ou c5 faut prendre des 4
fa c'est
la partie dure déjà depuis une heure on
sait que c'est complètement fini il n'y
a rien d'autre à dire fin ces
variants se passe et
c'est pas un plot c'est une moule il
s'accroche à son rocher
en le pion par deux pions de plus effacé
vraiment comment est partie pédagogique
là
fait rugir pourquoi tu jouerais ferro
qui se dit ou fait la même que les
facteurs ouanna hier terrible
ats faire un truc c'est qu'il a
abandonné en face nous aussi on espère
on espère qu'ils abandonnent en fait
c'est magnifique
je sais pas quoi y réfléchit c'est parce
qu'il fait en fait je peux pas vous
expliquer
le plan machiavélique parce que j'en
vois pas
parce que la vendre à un client en fait
j'en aurais peut-être pas mais je
jouerai vite je clique ray au hasard
jouerait quelques coups au hasard je
perdrais des quatre jurés dès que
j'abandonnerais mais où il fait un geste
et ré plus de me battre en fait si je
joue des coudes je prendrai plus quatre
minutes ou cinq minutes par coup en fait
je clique ray
l'a5 à de fioul qui crée vite
complètement dégoûté en faisant elle ça
se voit qu'ils y croient plus à précités
perdons et qui croit parce que tu le
vois pas ça c'est différent mais là ça
se voit qu'il le sait
il veut combattre des pubs je pense
cette stratégie
est clairement c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles les échecs ne marcheront
jamais en fait ça dans ça peut pas en
fait ça peut pas
je peux pas produire un spectacle ou
dans une position gagnante les gens
doivent attendre une heure et demie pour
savoir si c'est à gagner ou pas
classé
99,9 pour cent cuir ou djia gagne mais
ah bon
toujours une chance hein
mais ça peut pas durer une heure
de temps pau
ça peut pas on peut aussi longtemps
aussi apprécié ce type d'hommage art as
tu réussi à faire apprécier aux gens de
rester une heure et demi devant un truc
où il se passe rien tu es très doué
non
les jours comme ça en fait c'est pas
possible je veux avoir tous les jours un
truc où il se passe quelque chose après
deux heures où il ya six coups qui sont
joués avec le résultat qui est quasi
acquis quoi
c'est juste pas ça n'existe pas en fait
qui se passe vraiment un puisqu'il prend
l'exemple du tennis au tennis il joue
quoi ils envoient des trucs
là quand même des choses qui se passent
oh la la il se passe vraiment rien
à foot et si jouer c'est le coup qu'on
avait prévu le plus logique vient jouer
ali reza
ça
bref 6
il veut quoi
surtout ses seins qui veut quand il veut
f4 comprend des quatre
des huit
et je ne sais pas selon encore
trouve toujours transformé s'ils ne
veulent pas tout gâcher aller moi c'est
pas les joueurs les joueurs ils ont
raison de faire ce qu'ils font j'ai rien
contre ol ces gens qui organisent le les
tournois qui devrait un peu pensé quand
même
un minimum aux gens qui suivent
notez qu un ciseau c'est encore un cet
om et au tennis 6 0 6 0 en demi finale
de grand chelem c'est rare ou en
demi-finale de tournoi assez rare là
c'est quand même tous les jours quoi bon
thema le nombre de gens qui regardent le
temps à des chèques et emma le nombre de
gens qui regardent le tennis un
sas et ça c'est juste pas possible
ça c'est juste pas possible
c
surtout que tu aurais mis 25 mg diyar tu
mets 25 ou 30 minutes
c'est complexe
dumont était bien j'en ai déjà parlé
hier j'en reparle aujourd'hui pour ceux
qui étaient pas mais il mettait juste
vingt-cinq minutes de rage ou au 40e ça
permettait aux joueurs de récupérer du
temps quand même
ça permettait aux joueurs de récupérer
du temps quand même pour pouvoir un peu
jouer la finale mais sa garde et le
dynamisme pour pour le public quoi donc
c'était c'était le bon le bon ratio pour
faire des parties longues évidemment ils
partiront que c'est long ça durait cinq
heures en tout mais en fait ouais ça
permettait de couper un peu la poire en
deux on va dire ça comme ça
cette carence du côté joueurs donc je
partage et oued enfin c'est toujours
l'égoïsme de vouloir garder un truc que
tu as mis un côté joueurs enfin sport
professionnel c'est un spectacle
toute façon on peut garder les cadences
très longue pour les joueurs amateurs on
s'en fiche des tons amateurs en fait
personne regarde mais pour les pros il
faut aller un peu plus vite de toute
façon il récite 25 ou de théorie et ils
sont capables de jouer vite c il calcule
100 fois plus vite mille fois dix mille
fois cent mille fois plus vite que les
amateurs
pas toujours obligé de jouer avec les
mêmes règles en pro en amateur 1
non les 25 minutes à leur niveau ça
suffit d'or à la coupe du monde n'y a
pas eu dans glee spécial parce qu'ils
aient 25 minutes de rage ou un
accord avec toi c'est pas un truc qui
doit être fait pour le public c'est un
nivellement par le bas
comme tu souhaites 1
comme tu souhaites mais il se trouve que
je jouais en rapide c'est aussi une très
bonne chose
les a interrogés partie 6 heures ou à
une minorité d'amateurs ajouté partie 6
heures
non moi qu'on joue en amateur elle est
partie j'ai joué des parties de cette
heure 1
mais non mais le prochain sujet
secousses car la norme et vous
c'est pas ce qui fait le plus de vues le
poc j'aime c'est ce qui fait le plus de
vues parce que il ya des influenceurs
qui jouaient des gens très connus
mais tu mets les mêmes influences et le
poc j'aime c'est vraiment un très
mauvais exemple
c'est comme si tu prenais danse avec les
stars et tu disais qu'il y avait du
monde qui regardaient la danse c'est pas
un exemple pochep
demain tu fais un tour à de curling et
humer les joueurs du coach aime peut y
aura beaucoup de monde qui regardera pas
les échecs qu'il faut regarder l'époque
james et les gens qui jouent
complètement stupide comme rapport mais
bon peu importe on va l'arrêter discuter
avec le tchad parce qu'on va repartir on
va mal partir
c'est pas c'est parce qu'un exemple
correct
c'est bien le curling le curling en
reste c'est pas vrai j'ai failli jouer
en russie avec des potes je n'ai pas ce
qu'ils jouaient de temps en temps
texter la pétanque russe
on prend pas moi aussi j'aime quand ça
va plus vite mais au bout d'un moment je
dis jusqu'à vers la sphère estime j'aime
bien je trouve pas un mois en fait je
dis regardez partie par correspondance
frérot peut-être que c'est pas assez 6
heures
va regarder des parties par
correspondance faire là au bout d'un
moment on voit bien quand même que ça
ses fins c'est quand même long pour r au
bout d'un moment la vitesse d'exécution
des coups ça fait aussi partie de la
force des joueurs
au bout d'un moment ça avoir réalisé les
coûts rapidement ça fait aussi partie ii
d'une capacité que tu dois avoir
rapport vélo il se passe un pendant des
heures à aimer le vélo c'est tu regardes
pour pour les paysages c'est beau en
fait le vélo c'est bien filmé
allez on y va vous pouvez ne pas être
d'accord mais en fait
il se trouve que pourra jamais intéressé
beaucoup de monde tant qu'on aura des
trucs comme ça vous pouvez préférer les
cadences yongkang fait moi ça me ça me
dérange pas ça mais ça me dérange pas du
tout mais il se trouve que
ben
un
bout d'un moment
il ya juste des réalités physiques qui
sont là et que voilà retourner au vrai
tradition et jeux vont sans emploi au
bout d'un moment
il ya quelque chose qui doit se passer
quand même
il doit se passer quelque chose quand il
peut pas ne rien se passer jamais
mais en fait moi lorsque je trouve le
problème c'est pas vraiment ça le
problème du rajout en fait ça
m'embêterait pas qu'ils mettent cinq
heures pour la partie
directement mais en fait ce qui m'embête
avec le rajout duo 40e c'est qu'en fait
quand tu fais un spectacle en fait la
tension elles montrent la tension elle
monte elle culmine et ça s'arrête en
fait est là aux échecs fait que
l'attention elle monte elle culmine est
elle tombée comme ça pendant une heure
tu as un encéphalogramme plat et en fait
c'est ça le problème c'est pas pas
forcément le temps qu'ils voulaient
mettre deux heures dix par jour en fait
moi j'en ai rien à faire mettez 2h10
plus 30 secondes et puis et puis ça ça
change rien mais le problème en fait
c'est que c'est que ça ça tue souvent de
culmination en fait où ça doit s'arrêter
c'est comme le fait si on avait passé la
ligne finale et qu'après on remettait du
temps donc c'est même pas une question
de temps en fait changer le 1h40 plus 30
secondes par coup mais était 2h30
frustre plus de 30 secondes par coup
moi c'est pas un problème la partie elle
durera six heures et ça va mais c'est ce
problème de culmination
il se trouve que l'être humain
ne marche pas comme ça en fait
généralement nous quand on est une
culmination dans ce qu'on fait au
quotidien en soirée ou le matin pour
d'autres il trouve que tu as une
culmination et ça s'arrête en fait t'as
pas deux heures où il se passe rien et
puis ça reprend tout d'un coup et pour
moi le problème il est là c'est pas une
prime de cadence donc si vous voulez que
ça joue six heures moi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] ce sage ou 10h 20h c'est pas un
problème mais ça doit culminer à un
moment donné
si non en fait tu viens quand il se
passe quoi tu sais pas le résultat tu
t'es encore attendre deux plombes après
c'est un problème
climatique ouais donc quand il rajoute
que 20 ou 25 minutes pourquoi pas à la
rigueur bon sassareu le rallonge un peu
mais tu restes un peu dans le feu de
l'action quoi
à se dessiner mais le gros du film se
passe à 1h15 apprête à 40 minutes où il
se passe rien quoi ça marcherait pas
après le conte russe a dû refaire la
partie moyenne va peut-être plus traîner
en longueur je sais pas
jean saisrien enfin débrouillez vous en
faites un moi ce que je vois c'est qu'il
ya personne qui regarde
tu vas en anglais il est à 1500
spectateurs organique les frérots 1500
spectateurs organique
1500 pour la dixième ronde d'avira web
n'y a pas de joueurs américains à 20 pas
de chance il ya caruana tableau 1 vous
allez lire abeilles a pas de joueur
anglais à 20 pas de chance il ya david
howell table 2
[Musique]
quelque 4500 non mais tu compte les gens
qui attendent chatte y avait à peu près
1500 personnes
1500 personnes pour un truc qui qualifie
attente on a le plus important dans un
tournoi qui coûtent des millions à faire
enfin je sais pas mais les échecs on est
plus en français quoi c'est quand même
pas normal
1 ou non nous on est tout organique
parce qu'on n'a pas de on n'a pas de
boost
bizarre on va dire par pas bizarre on
n'a pas de boost particulière je sais
pas combien on est maintenant en mer
mais peu importe et puis même si on
était 1500 en france s est tu dois faire
un ratio deux fois 20 en anglais ferment
on peut importe si c'est pas la question
géraud bout d'un moment faut se poser
des questions
cette finale est très intéressante mais
si moi j'ai 4500 en vigueur si
c'est parce que c'est cette chaîne en
fait
cette finale elle n'est pas intéressante
elle est complètement gagnant quand on
sait qui va gagner on n'est pas là pour
passer une heure et demie dessus
ils n'ont pas eu non on va pas passer
1h30 là dessus si la joue avec 20
minutes ou une heure à la pendule le
plan pour aller bouffer le pion c5 il
aurait fait pareil il va échanger il va
[ __ ] b3 il va pousser le pion à il va
gagner enfin je leur bout d'un moment
ça va c'est pas
mais c'est pas moi le problème la fia
c'est le problème du rythme c'est une
question de rythme
c'est une question de rythme ccn qui
c'est une question de monter de rythme
et de baisses comme ça et après ils
voient les non ça va pas en fait c'est
pas possible
impossible la finale en soi qu'il la
joue je suis pas du tout contre enfin ol
a raison de le faire en tout cas
réserve les temps forts et faibles c'est
pour ça que j'ai 25 30 minutes ça fait
un petit temps faibles ça permettront de
prendre un petit café de récup et hop on
se relance dans la finale à la non en
fait
on va pas laisser ses vieux ont aussi
besoin de temps tu penses que les viewer
ils ont ils ont le temps de venir de 13h
à 18h 15 poursuivre une partie ni eau ni
bah nan mais franchement les gens ils
font des trucs dans leur life laddh
16h50 tu leur dis bon la partie elle est
presque fini on va voir si fier route
jamais gagnants les mecs ils ont pas
1h40 à attendre pour voir la fin
faudrait savoir quand ça finit un truc
de cyclisme qui te donne à peu près
l'heure du sprint là tu viens tu
repasses il se passe rien n'y a rien qui
change fin c'est un problème quoi si tu
dis bon pendant 40 minutes tu auras le
résultat final mais là en fait tu leur
dis bon bah les gars ça va durer encore
deux heures
c'est trop
tu leur dis ça dure encore 30-40 minutes
les gens y passent et reviennent ma
chambre ils sont là mais là c'est trop
non en france c'est vraiment et que
c'est incroyable le public issue et tout
c'est vraiment exceptionnel c'est la
seule langue tu vas tu vas dans les
autres langues en organique qui sont 100
à regarder le tournoi enfin
200 300 familles à personne en fait
qu'ils regardent dans des pays où
normalement il ya beaucoup plus de monde
parce que la frange crois que ça va être
le 5 ou 6ème pays en langue sur twitter
en fait ils devraient globalement on
devrait être beaucoup moins
c'est triste parce que c'est un beau jeu
les échecs et ça mérite d'être plus plus
regarder les échecs mérite mieux en fait
en russie les regarde un peu non pas du
tout
malheureusement
les échecs mérite mais en fait
c'est ça le truc
enfin moi j'ai toujours pensé en tout
cas
k
je le pense vraiment
5 et puis va recycler le fou comme je le
disais tout à l'heure en c2 il va
réussir à pousser le pion il va gagner
tranquillement en plus même le langage
corporel dowell tu vois qui sait que
c'est fini aussi
parce que là en fait il va réussir à
faire [ __ ] qu'as tu es fou prend h5
maintenant
la tête avoir un stock de temps global
prédéfinis way
ou alors des petit rajout mais pas un
truc aussi long
bref car tu es fou cinq femmes c'est
gagner à doha après fou d un il va
gagner un quatrième pion 1 on va y aller
faire x 5 allez hop on va remplir une
autre faille attention proches ont kovy
site jancovici de lega anxiogène on
arrive au 60e coup on va perdre deux
feuilles de papier
attention
c'est anxiogène là
faut pas qu'ils dépassent le 60e sauvons
du papier les amis sauveront des arbres
arrachés anxiogène et de la
relation que ce gène aide rail va faire
flouer encore il va essayer de la tenir
à aimer fouet quatre proches 5ème ça
fait mal hein on a peut-être du bol
hyper tête à chaque avant le 60e ali
reza qui pourrait sauver deux feuilles
de papier
plein de rage au 60e 60e il ya encore 15
ou 25 minutes chez plus froid 15 mais
surtout au 60e coup il ya une nouvelle
feuille de papier qui part
du coût du coût des deux feuilles de
matches qu'ils repartent quoi
mais je pense que cali réserve à sauver
la forêt
j'ordonne élus qu'avant de forest qui
vont être contents qu'ils vont lui faire
une scène de liesse quand il va quand il
va finir cette partie aux îles y pense
david howell il est en train de se dire
je peux sauver une feuille de papier en
abandonnant maintenant il la regarde il
a regardé en train lui dire j'aime pas
trop les arbres quand même ouais je suis
pas sur la fin s'il te plaît abandonne
je veux pas qu'on utilise pour rien
et là je vais voir un petit peu d'eau tu
commences à me parler un peu un peu
poliment j'ai quand même vérifier qui a
rien à faire et s'il te plaît s'il te
plaît david abandonne abandonne je
jugerai avec toi demain tu devrais
écrire sur moi demain
laisse moi vivre encore 24 heures s'il
te plaît non non non non non non non
j'ai encore un put environ à 4 frérot je
vais la jouer jusqu'au bout je vais la
jouer jusqu'au bout je vais pas
abandonner je vais y aller aussi s'il te
plaît s'il te plaît y'a plus rien à
faire il est très fort en face
il a quand même choke hier contre
caruana tout peut encore arriver ce pas
sûr qu'ils sachent diagne avec quatre
pions de plus alireza fiant aux jo je
suis pas bien sûr de mon côté j'ai
encore vingt mille 25 minutes qui
reviennent je peux encore faire le taf
ainsi si si je t'assure il va gagner
c'est sûr à 100%
on va quand même vérifier ça on va quand
même vérifier ça ouais ça joue encore
les amis il est pas bien sûr où elle il
n'est pas bien sûr que fouet quatre
fourgons h5 ce soit vraiment bien
gagnant il ya que trois pions de plus
avec un quatrième qui tombe
n'est pas bien sûr la
voilà il n'est pas bien sûr l'ordinateur
doit donner plus 25 je pensais déjà matt
forcer ces quatre pions plus y'a rien à
voir même en blitz tu abandonnes mais
nan nan nan nan nan on va être bien sûr
bon après j'ai rien contre le joueur
comme vous dit c'est vraiment je troll
un peu mais c'est vraiment la cadence
qui pourra voir là le gars il a le droit
de jouer il joue il n'y a pas de souci
raphaël est en train d en bout de sa
lifeco en train de se dire si aux
candidats ils font chier comme ça moi
j'y vais pas honnêtement alireza là il
est en train de se dire ça idiot aux
candidats c'est la même cadence les mecs
sont aussi relooke ol frères j'y vais
pas frère je vous laisse la place maxime
retourne six mois j'y vais pas moi j'y
vais pas les frérots rien à [ __ ] des
candidats j'y vais pas match contre carl
scène balech balech jamais tu dois
m'asseoir en face de lui c'est trop
c'est trop un jeu de rageux j'y vais pas
les gars j'y vais pas j'arrête ma
carrière et il va il va sortir de la
partie les mecs boyard félicitations
vous êtes favoris demain pour le
candidat les frères j'arrête les frères
j'arrête je veux plus jouer ce truc là
je veux plus jouer ce truc là je te jeta
sur ça ça se termine comme ça
aujourd'hui oh ils abandonnent trop la
feuille de papier qui a carry on n'était
pas bien sûr quand même quand il a
abandonné il a abandonné en mode bon
j'abandonne mais franchement j'aurais dû
te la joues encore quelques coups non il
n'ya pas abandonner comme ça on va frère
je te la laisse celle là mais en vrai de
vrai si je te la joues c'est pas sûr tu
la gagnes
c'est pas sûr en vrai de vrai en vrai de
vrai de vrai peut-être tulle haratch de
la lesse non il n'y a pas eu un peu de
savoir qui va vraiment à la fin
je pense tu pouvais pas la gagner je
pense tu pouvais pas la gagner
six jeux
quand même au quand même attention
attention alireza non il a gagné pas tu
la gagnes et pas franchement ce jeu
jusqu'au bout tu as gagne pas j'ai vu
baron fois avec deux dames il a pas maté
j'ai vu par enfouis l'apama tes frères
arrête de n'en arrête de te raconter des
life pas dit que tu n'en as pas dit que
tu m'as tu ailles n'ont franchement pas
dit que tu m'attaques de dames 1
franchement pas sûr or il y avait des
idées de pâtes encore
il y avait des idées de pâtes encore
frère à y avait il y avait des il y
avait des ressources n'avait jamais
encore des ressources j'avais encore des
ressources
mais voilà j'étais fatigué j'ai envie
d'aller bouffer j'ai un peu la dalle
j'ai préféré arrêter là mais avait de la
ressource
en vrai
voyez des idées de patois
bon les gars sur ce banc la partie est
terminée donc sur cette victoire d'ali
reza c'est une excellente nouvelle pour
la france les amis quand même on a
encore les chars palais où la france
quand même qui sourit maxime qui a perdu
mon finit quand même sur sur la victoire
d'ali reza la france est là et demande
jouera pour une voire deux places aux
candidats il faudra tout donner on lâche
rien la france la france qui est dans le
box dans le bon sens j'en sais rien la
france allant vers la france la france
la france qui gagne
bravo alireza max a perdu match a fait
nul il fait 10 perdus mais bon c'est un
peu comme une défaite il faudra gagner
demain peu importe il faudra gagner
demain
mais on tentera on tentera du coup de
faire le doublé mais déjà sûr on nous
dit nul d'alireza demain avec les noirs
et après en espérant que maxime gagne
aussi et qui réussissent avec un peu de
réussite au départage a coiffé ses
adversaires sur le poteau merci à tous
d'avoir suivi ce live et on se retrouve
demain pour de nouvelles aventures merci
à tous ciao ciao